bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat pendant la suspension
des travaux du Sénat je vous propose de
voir ou de revoir les temps fort de la
dernière session parlementaire et place
ce matin à l'audition de Jean-Bernard
Lévi le PDG de DF auditionné au mois
d'avril par la commission des affaires
économiques présidée par le sénateur les
républicains Jean-Claude Lenoir
l'occasion pour Jean-Bernard Levi de
s'exprimer pendant 2hes sur la situation
financière compliquée du géant français
de l'électricité dont la dette atteint
37 milliards d'euros au mois d'avril
d'ailleurs l'État actionnaire à hauteur
de 85 % du groupe a injecté 3 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires dans les caisses
une situation qui met en difficulté les
investissements prévus notamment la mise
en sûreté des centrales existantes et
les projets d'avenir comme les PR
Flamanville Taishan mais surtout incle
point un un projet désormais controversé
qui doit prendre place en
Grande-Bretagne et pour lequel
Jean-Bernard levvi milite très
activement retour tout de suite à cette
audition nous allons vous entendre
monsieur le Président détailler ces
mesures mais comporte notamment le
soutien de l'État à travers une
augmentation de capital et par le
versement de son dividende en action
pour les deux prochaines années en même
temps baisse des investissements et que
supplémentaire efforts qui seront fait
session d'actifs et cetera bon il reste
que certains projets de DF sont
aujourd'hui contestés nous allons en
reparler notamment concernant incle
point mais d'ors et déjà et avant de
vous entendre monsieur le Président vous
posez quelques questions qui vont vous
éclairer
sur la demande de la
Commission concernant Inle point est-il
exact acte qu'il y a des garanties
euh sur le prix mais pas sur le volume
c'estàdire est-ce
que le consommateur britannique s'engage
à consommer un certain volume
d'électricité garanti qu'il est pour ce
qui est du prix quel est d'autre part
son partage des risques entre EDF et son
partenaire chinois
CGN avec lequel
EDF construit euh plusieurs réacteurs en
Chine
euh la question aussi de la
disponibilité
euh de ces réacteurs et de la durée de
réalisation de
l'investissement est-ce que les durées
annoncées seront seront respectées vous
alleer d'autre part bien sûr nous parler
d'arvage je veux pas prolonger trop
puisque j'ai déjà dit à mes collègues
qui onont 2 minutes je le redis ici pour
poser une question il me reste 10
secondes
pour vous dire qu'il y aura également
des questions sur
faenheim sur la réduction de la part du
nucléaire
euh qui est prévu par la loi de
transition
énergétique annoncé pour une part dans
le cadre de la PPE mais incomplète
puisque la part du nucléaire de la PPE
n'est pas connue il y a aussi quantité
d'autres questions qui sont relayées par
euh l'équipe que vous avez devant vous
euh qui est la commission des Affaires
d'économie monsieur le Président je vous
donne la parole merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs je suis j'ai grand plaisir à
venir m'entretenir avec vous euh vous
parlez quelques minutes euh de DF et
puis bien sûr surtout répondre à à vos
questions dans dans quelques instants la
la situation deedf suscite beaucoup de
questions et euh je dirais le le sujet
majeur et c'est pour ça que nous nous
sommes permis de vous distribuer une
planche un graphique le problème majeur
c'est que nous devons aujourd'hui sur
notre principal marché celui de la vente
de la production d'électricité ce qu'on
appelle le marché de gros nous nous
avons aujourd'hui un marché comme vous
l'avez sur les le document distribué un
marché très déprimé où les prix ont été
divisés par 2 en 2 ans ils sont
aujourd'hui autour de 27 à 28 € contre
plus de 50 € en 2014 et même 60 €
précédemment les raisons sont
principalement la baisse du prix des
matières premières énergétique comme le
charbon et et le gaz et le pétrole
derrière et puis aussi le fait que la
croissance n'est pas revenue alors que
de nouvelles capacités de production
vous l'avez dit monsieur le Président se
déploi de façon soutenue en France et
dans les pays limitrophes nous ne sommes
pas les seuls à connaître une situation
difficile et et et je dirais même que la
plupart des énergéticiens en France et
dans les pays voisins ont rencontré des
difficultés plutôt plus fortes que les
nôtres ils ont tous eu des résultats
déficitaires certains d'entre eux sont
en train de se cinder en en deux ou
plusieurs entreprises indépendant il
n'est question ni de l'un ni de l'autre
pour EDF nous sommes un groupe intégré
et qui a vocation à le rester et nous
sommes restés là aussi chaque année
bénéficiaire nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui eu le moindre exercice
déficitaire et je voudrais souligner que
c'est un hommage rendu à la compétence à
la mobilisation des des salariés et
aussi au choix historique qu'a fait la
France en faveur du nucléaire qui comme
vous le savez représente aujourd'hui 75
% de la production et qui nous permet de
mettre à la disposition de nos clients
une énergie et surtout une électricité
bien moins cher que chez tous nos
voisins une électricité abondante qui
assure la sécurité d'approvisionnement
de la France qui nous permet d'exporter
donc de maintenir ou de créer des
emplois en France et puis bien sûr une
électricité qui est particulièrement
décarbonée à mon arrivée j'ai estimé
nécessaire de donner un cadre de travail
à long terme pour EDF cela s'appelle
notre stratégie cap 2030 une stratégie
qui s'inscrit dans la transition
énergétique et qui est fondé sur nos nos
convictions de ce que sera le monde de
demain demain l'énergie sera bas carbone
il y a des facteurs climatiques des
facteurs géopolitiques qui fait que il y
a une forte demande une forte demande de
l'opinion publique à ce que l'énergie
contribue à limiter les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre demain les
consommateurs seront aussi des acteurs
en matière énergétique historiquement le
consommateur était passif demain il va
s'occuper lui-même dep piloter sa
consommation grâce à des outils
numériques il sera lui-même un
producteur il pourra vendre
l'électricité bah à lui-même mais aussi
à ses voisins demain nous verrons que de
nombreux moteurs de la croissance
économique fonctionnent à l'électricité
j'en citerai deux la mobilité électrique
que ça soit les transports collectifs ou
les véhicules individuels et puis le
développement rapide des technologies de
l'information et de la communication qu'
pense data à Center ou que l'on pense à
tous les objets du quotidien que nous
avons aujourd'hui dans nos domicile et
qui marche à l'électricité et
quelquefois nous laissons tous les uns
les autres n'est-ce pas nos chargeurs
toute la journée à chauffer on pourrait
d'ailleurs faire attention moi le
premier bien sûr et donc dans ce modèle
où la la production décentralisée va se
superposer au modèle centralisé et
hiérarchique actuel EDF qui est
évidemment l'archétype du modèle
centralisé et hiérarchique doit apporter
des réponses et c'est l'objet de notre
stratégie cap 2030 notre premier
objectif c'est de développer des offres
compétitives numériques et
décentralisées que nos clients attendent
que ça soi nos clients ménages que ça
soit les territoires les collectivités
locales qui cherchent eux-mêmes à
déterminer leur propre transition
énergétique le deuxième objectif c'est
en matière de production nous avons un
mix carbone particulièrement remarquable
nous jouons très bien de la
complémentarité entre les énergies
nouvelles renouvelables l'hydraulique
autre énergie renouvelable mais plus
ancienne et bien sûr le le nucléaire et
puis nous voulons bénéficier de
complément de croissance pour le groupe
EDF dans des zones géographiques
dynamiques où nous pourrons apporter
notre expertise d'électricien bas
carbone nous avons une caractéristique
qui est très forte en matière
d'innovation chez EDF nous sommes l'un
des rares électriciens sinon le seul à
avoir historiquement de fortes capacités
d'innovation autonome puisque nous
dépensons chaque année environ 600
millions d'euros à travers des équipes
fortes de 2000 chercheurs en matière de
recherche et développement
ces chercheurs sont principalement
localisés en en France mais ils le sont
aussi dans d'autres pays du monde et
j'étais récemment en Californie nous
avons une petite équipe qui est au cœur
de la Silicone Valley pour justement
être au courant de toutes ces
interactions entre énergie et numérique
qui sont très importantes pour le le
monde de demain nous voulons nous
inscrire dans des écosystèmes travailler
avec les les startup les incubateurs et
bien sûr les acteurs du monde
scientifique et académique et ça se
traduit déjà concrètement puisque 10
millions de nos clients 100 millions de
nos clients ont déjà un espace client
digital et notre application qui aide
nos clients à faire des économies
d'énergie qui s'appelle équilibre est
déjà en usage dans 1 million de foyers à
travers notamment les smart smartph nous
voulons aussi développer des solutions
décentralisées pour répondre à la
demande des collectivités territoriales
et souvent on le sait les solutions
innovantes passent par les territoires
je suis frappé lors de mes déplacements
dans les grandes métropoles provinciales
de voir l'effervescence d'innovation
qu'il y a et le rôle que nous jouons
localement pour faciliter la mise en
place de solutions adéquat de solutions
sur mesure pour ces différents
territoire nous voulons donc identifier
et valoriser les potentiels d'énergie
renouvelablebl local comme par par
exemple la chaleur renouvelable la
biomasse ou la géothermie pour alimenter
des réseaux de chaleur ou de froid nous
sommes au premier plan en matière de
solution de mobilité électrique nous
innovons dans l'éclairage public et bien
sûr et et Madame la Ministre seolen
royale il fait référence fréquemment
nous avons à innover et nous le faisons
en matière d'efficacité énergétique des
bâtiments je donnerai quelques exemples
l'ensemble éolien catalan 96 MW qui
permettra dès cet été de valoriser le
potentiel de vent des Pyrénées
Orientales produisant l'équivalent de la
consommation d'une ville de 120000
habitants l'une des plus grandes fermes
éoliennes de France deuxème exemple en
Vendé nous travaillons avec le syndicat
départemental d'énergie de manière à
déployer 125 bornes de recharge
électrique pour mailler le territoire du
département cette infrastructure son
exploitation et sa gestion en sont
assurés par notre filiale
saétrelle le deuxè axe de notre
stratégie c'est la la production bas
carbone je ne rappellerai pas le le
succès de la de la COP 21 mais je
voudrais dire que EDF de ce point de
vue-là est d'ors et déjà exemplaire
puisque nous disposons d'un parc de
production qui n'émet que 15 g de CO2
par kilwh produit et que c'est un
chiffre exceptionnel c'est 20 fois moins
que la moyenne des pays européens 15 g
20 fois moins que 310 g les les voisins
européens cela est grâce au choix
historique remarqua qui ont été fait
dans notre pays des choix historiques
qui font que notre parc de production
repose essentiellement sur des des
énergies renouvelables et sur du
nucléaire vous le savez nous avons des
ambitions fortes en matière de
développement des énergies renouvelable
d'abord nous avons encore à exploiter
davantage notre potentiel hydraulique et
puis nous avons aussi à faire reposer
nos efforts sur l'éolien le solaire et
la chaleur renouvelable on l'ignore
souvent mais EDF est le premier
producteur d'énergie renouvelable en
Europe et l'un des premiers dans le
monde derrière les opérateurs chinois
chaque année nous investissons 2
milliards d'euros un peu plus de 2
milliards d'euros pour produire de
nouvelles capacités de renouvela soit un
peu plus que notre investissement dans
les nouveaux moyens de production
d'électricité d'origine nucléaire notre
objectif à l'horizon 2030 c'est de
doubler la capacité du parc
d'électricité renouvelable que nous
exploitons en le passant de 28 à 50
Gow je voudrais souligner que notre
présence en matière d'énergie
renouvelable se se déploie en France
mais aussi dans d'autres pays nous nous
avons des contrats d'approvisionnement
importants avec des des grands noms
comme Ikea Google ou Microsoft et je je
vous donne volontiers un exemple un parc
éolien que nous
avons lancé mise en service près de
Chicago 175 MW 103 éolien qui vont
alimenter des Data Center de Microsoft
qui lui veut vis-à-vis de ses clients
pouvoir afficher qu'il fournit ses
clients avec de l'énergie renouvelable
moi je suis convaincu que notre avenir
repose sur le bon mix entre le
renouvelable et le nucléaire le
nucléaire apporte bien sûr une
excellente disponibilité une excellente
prévisibilité et un coût très compétitif
les renouvelables apportent un
complément décarboné très puissant
lorsqu'il ventent ou qu'il fait soleil
et nous avons donc mis en œuvre des
méthodes de gestion de notre parc qui
sont assez uniques au monde et qui nous
permettent de moduler la production
nucléaire de manière à ce qu'elle
complète la production renouvelable
nous devons donc au-delà du
développement des énergies renouvelables
conforter aussi notre parc nucléaire
existant ça veut dire vous le savez
faire le grand carénage programme
indispensable un programme de grande
ampleur pour l'ensemble de la filière
nucléaire porteur d'emploi mais aussi un
programme très rentable pour notre
collectivité nationale et dès mon
arrivée à EDF j'ai demandé au Conseil
d'Administration qu'il a voté que le
principe de ce programme soit conforté
ça a été fait en janvier 2015 nous
allons donc prolonger la durée de
fonctionnement de nos centrales tout en
augmentant encore le niveau de sûreté et
tout ceci faisant se faisant sous le
contrôle et sous réserve de l'accord de
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire le coût
du grand carénage 51 milliards d'euros
courants de 2014 à 2025 c'est 15 % de
moins que notre évaluation initiale nous
avons pu optimiser les coûts du du grand
carénage et le grand carénage va être
dans les années qui viennent le premier
poste de dépenses d'investissement pour
EDF sur les 10 années c'est en moyenne
40 % de nos investissements annuels que
nous consacrerons à ce
programme le grand carénage c'est donc
un bon investissement puisqu'il
permettra aux Français de continuer à
bénéficier de l'électricité au meilleur
coût puisqu'il s'agit pour l'essentiel
de conserver en améliorant la sûreté de
conserver des installations existantes
mais nous nous devons aussi préparer
l'avenir du nucléaire avec les les PR et
notre premier objectif qui est
véritablement essentiel on dit
volontiers stratégique c'est de mettre
en service le Pr de Flamanville nous
avons franchi il y a un mois au mois de
mars comme prévu le premier jalon clé
conformément au calendrier que nous
avions mis à jour à l'été 2015 et qui
prévoit un démarrage du réacteur au 4e
trimestre 2018 une nouvelle organisation
industrielle a été mise en place pour
garantir la maîtrise du champ chtier
avec nos partenaires de façon beaucoup
plus transparente beaucoup
plus partagé et je crois que cette
nouvelle organisation du chantier en
tout cas pour l'instant çaavère
nettement plus efficace et puis il y a
bien sûr le le dossier inclep sur lequel
vous m'avez posé une première série de
questions prochainement le conseil
d'administration aura à se prononcer sur
le lancement de cet investissement pour
la construction de deux pr en
Grande-Bretagne cette décision je crois
qu'elle aurait été déjà prise si le prix
de marché était resté à à 50 €. elle
aurait déjà été soumise au vote du
conseil d'administration mais avec la
baisse brutal des prix de marché qui est
intervenu à la fin de l'année
2015 cette conjoncture m'a imposé de
commencer par sécuriser la trajectoire
financière du Groupe EDF ne pas se
lancer dans cet investissement qui est
important sans avoir sécurisé la
trajectoire financière de DF ceci est
fait vous y avez fait allusion à travers
les annonces euh le jour de notre
conseil d'administration vendredi 22
vendredi dernier j'y reviendrai dans
dans un instant j'ai aussi décidé de
consulter le comité central d'entreprise
le CCE car les représentants du
personnel les élus du CCE m'en ont fait
la demande de manière unanime mais c'est
un projet qui je crois conserve toutes
ses qualités et qui et qui devra se
faire pour de nombreuses raisons le
premier c'est que le ce projet est
extrêmement rentable nous avons le
bénéfice de ce qui s'appelle le contrat
pour différents avec le gouvernement
britannique ce contrat pour différence
sécurise un prix de vente pendant 35 ans
de 2025 à 2060 ce prix est indexé sur
l'inflation ceci nous permet d'afficher
un taux de rentabilité de
l'investissement d'environ 9 % par an 9
% par an sur les 70 ans qui viennent 10
ans de construction 60 ans
d'exploitation et 95 % de cette valeur
créée est réalisée pendant les 35 où le
prix est garanti ce contrat aide
d'État a été validé par la commission
européenne il est donc robuste il n'est
pas fixé par une loi qui pourrait être
modifiée unilatéralement par
gouvernement britannique à un moment ou
à un autre c'est un contrat bilatéral
entre l'État britannique et l'entreprise
que nous sommes notre filiale qui
construira et exploitera les deux
réacteurs et puis nous son pas seuls
nous investissons vous l'avez cité aussi
avec nos partenaires chinois CGN nos
partenaires de 30 ans qui connaissent le
Pr puisqu'ils ont construit deux
actuellement à taan et qui ont décidé de
porter un/ers de l'investissement total
soit 8 milliards d'euros ce projet est
rentable il se déroule dans un excellent
climat de confiance avec nos partenaires
chinois et britanniques ce projet est
aussi mû tous les accords avec l'État
britannique et avec notre partenaire CGN
sont prêts ils ont ont été approuvés par
la Commission européenne les contrats
avec les principaux fournisseurs et
prestataires sont finalisés je rappelle
que ce n'était pas le cas au moment du
lancement de Flam enville les équipes
ont été organisées elles sont prêtes les
dirigeants du projet ont été désignés
bien sûr inkle point intégrera le retour
d'expérience de flamandville I et de
Tachan c'est déjà le cas en matière
d'ingénierie et de conduite de chantier
ce sera le cas en ce qui concerne la
mise en service
puisque nous prévoyons que le premier
béton de sûreté c'est-à-dire l'érection
du bâtiment le début de l'érection du
bâtiment nucléaire qui interviendra en
2019 ce premier béton de sûreté
interviendra après la mise en service de
Taishan 1 et de flamandville 3 ces deux
réacteurs d'inklep seront donc le 5e et
le 6e pr à être construit dans le monde
alors on parle beaucoup des risques chez
demander vu l'ampleur du projet avec ma
mes références industrielles dans ce
secteur et dans d'autres secteurs j'ai
demandé qu'une revue de risque soit
conduite fin 2015 elle a établi que les
risques sont connus et surmontables
moyennant la mise en œuvre d'une série
de recommandations et j'ai décidé
d'appliquer l'ensemble de ces
recommandation il y aura bien sûr au fur
et à mesure de la vie de ce projet de 10
ans d'autres revues de risque c'est une
procédure habituelle pour des projets de
cette
ampleur je voudrais vous dire que le
report d' ne me semble pas opportun
certains évoquent la possibilité de
reporter le projet après la mise en
service de flamandville et de taan et ce
n'est à mes yeux ni nécessaire ni
faisable les risques sont nombreux le
report de plusieurs années amènerait le
gouvernement britanique à se tourner
vers des solutions alternatives et il ne
manque pas aujourd'hui de constructeur
de réacteurs nucléaires qui
s'engouffreraient dans la brèche ainsi
créée le contrat pour différence
deviendrait Cadu il faudrait renégocier
avec le le gouvernement britannique et
avec la Commission de Bruxelles le
report du projet mettrait aussi en péril
notre partenariat avec CGN notre
partenaire chinois enfin nous devrions
également renégocier les contrats avec
les principaux fournisseurs qui
représentent environ 70 % des coûts et
les dépenses déjà engagées sur le projet
seraient en grande partie perdu je suis
donc convaincu que incle point doit se
faire il doit se faire maintenant dès
que nous aurons eu l'avis du comité
central
d'entreprise je voudrais souligner que
la construction de ces pr ouvre des
perspectives absolument majeure pour
l'ensemble de notre filière française
d'excellence dans le nucléaire on pense
qu'il y a environ 220000 emplois en
France qui sont concerné par le
nucléaire le projet nous permettra de
disposer d'une offre plus compétitive
pour le renouvellement du parc lorsque
la question se posera en France il nous
permettra aussi d'être crédible à
l'exportation comment être crédible pour
vendre des pr à l'exportation si ne nous
ne commandons pas à nous-mêmes nos
propres
produits je voudrais revenir maintenant
sur le contexte
économique la courbe que je vous ai
distribué montre l'ampleur et la
rapidité de l'évolution des des prix de
marché de de
l'électricité les causes de cette baisse
des prix sont sont bien connues il y a
des facteurs de consommation qui
augmentent la consommation
d'électricité mais il y a
aussi des facteurs de diminution de la
consommation d'électricité le plus
important et et nous n'en sommes
satisfait c'est l'efficacité énergétique
c'est le fait que les consommateurs les
entreprises les administrations ou ou ou
les ménages sont plus attentifs mais il
y a aussi des facteurs de baisse durable
de la consommation d'électricité dans un
phénomène qu'il faut déplorer c'est
celui de la
désindustrialisation de notre pays qui
crée une baisse de la demande
d'électricité lorsque les usines
fortement consommatrices s'arrêtent et
on sait que dans la durée nous avons
perdu malheureusement des emplois
industriels en particulier dans ce qu'on
appelle les industries
électrointensives ces facteurs de baisse
ne sont pas vraiment compensés en volume
par la hausse induite par la démographie
par la hausse induite par le
développement des nouveaux usages de
l'électricité je parlais des Data Center
ou des véhicules électriques ce qui fait
que la demande d'électricité est stable
depuis plusieurs années alors que
l'offre augmente chaque année et que par
exemple en France nous avons connecté la
France 2000 MW d'énergie nouvelle
renouvelable en 2015 ce phénomène
apparaît durable les marchés nous
donnent des indications sur les prix
dans 2 ou 3 ans et il semble que ces
prix ne sont pas destinés à remonter
fortement avant 2 ou 3 ans ceci crée
pour EDF une situation très différente
de ce qu'elle était précédemment
pourquoi et bien parce que DF est
beaucoup plus fortement exposé au prix
de marché qu'il ne l'était il y a
quelques années euh il y a quelques
années nous avions moins de 20 % de nos
production qui se vendait sur le marché
principalement la production pour les
industriels aujourd'hui c'est 65 % de
notre production qui se vend sur le
marché puisque nous avons
progressivement ouvert plutôt fait mis
fin au prix au prix régulés en
particulier sur les entreprises de toute
nature ce qu'on appelit les tarifs
jaunes et verts et nous avons donc le
plein effet en 2016 et 2017 de cette
baisse des des prix des prix de marché
avec 65 % plus plus de trois fois plus
le chiffre d'il y a 3 ans de notre
production qui se vend aujourd'hui sur
sur le marché et donc ceci crée les
conditions d'un déséquilibre durable sur
les comptes d'EDF
entre les capacités de financement et
les besoins d'investissement ce
déséquilibre durable il est par certains
côtés soluble mais à condition de
prendre des mesures et c'est tout
l'objet du plan que j'ai présenté en
conseil d'administration vendredi
dernier et que je vais vous décrire
maintenant ces mesures sont
indispensables car nous n'avons pas le
choix que d'investir il n'est pas
question que nous nous arrêtions
d'investir je l'ai dit nous avons besoin
de faire le grand carénage et de
conforter le parc existant nous avons
besoin de développer les énergies
nouvelles renouvelable et de doubler
notre parc installé d'ici à 2030 nous
avons besoin de poursuivre le
développement de notre filière nucléaire
avec de nouveaux réacteurs Flamanville
Taishan incle point puis des réacteurs
qui seront construits en France pour
commencer le renouvellement du parc à
l'horizon 2030 et les décisions seront à
prendre vers 2020 et puis nous avons
aussi besoin d'investissement important
dans le réseau et vous qui êtes souvent
très proche du terrain dans les dans les
territoires vous savez bien qu'il y a
une forte demande pour la qualité de
service telle qu'elle est fournie par
notre filiale ERDF qu'il y a des besoins
d'enfouissement qu'il y a des besoins de
raccordement d'énergie renouvelable et
puis il y a un programme particulier
dans lequel nous sommes engagés c'est
celui du compteur
lin pour faire face à cette situation la
trajectoire financière que j'ai donc
présenté au conseil d'administration
vendredi dernier vise à sécuriser
l'avenir de DF dans un monde qui a
beaucoup changé qui est beaucoup plus
difficile qu'il qu'il ne l'était alors
quel est le contenu de ce plan d'abord
il s'agit d'optimiser nos
investissements ce n'est pas parce que
nos investissements sont indispensables
qu'il ne faut pas les les les les
optimiser et nous
avons établi que certains des
investissement qui se termine je pense à
la rénovation des moyens de production
dans les îles comme la Corse ou les les
îles des département d'outremer je pense
à la terminaison proche à la terminaison
prochaine de la construc construction
d'un terminal gazier à à dkererc je
pense à la construction de notre
magnifique campus de de sacclé voilà des
programmes qui se terminent voilà aussi
des exemples d'investissement que
peut-être nous ne lancerions plus
aujourd'hui dans cette conjoncture plus
difficile et avec cette plus forte
sélectivité de nos investissements mais
tout en restant cohérent avec la
stratégie cap 2030 et bien nous estimons
pouvoir sur le périmètre existant
économiser environ 2 milliards d'euros
d'ici à 2018 et faire que nos
investissements sur le P è existant se
passeront d'environ 12 milliards 7 à
environ 10 milliards et demi d'euros de
2015 à
2018 nous aurons bien sûr des
investissements nouveaux qu'il faut
poursuivre qui ne sont pas dans ces
chiffres tels que Linky tels que
flamandville et inclay
point nous avons à réduire aussi nos
charges opérationnelles nous avons déjà
réduit nos coûts en 2015 c'est la
première fois depuis des années et des
années que DF réduisait ses charges
opérationnelles nous les avons réduit de
de 300 millions d'euros soit 1,4 % en en
2015 lors de la présentation des comptes
en février j'ai annoncé un objectif de
réduction de nos charges opérationnelles
de 700 millions d'euros en 2018 par
rapport à 2015 vendredi dernier en
conseil nous avons annoncé et et rendu
publ quelques heurs après que nous
portons cet objectif de 700 millions
d'euros de réduction en 2018 à au moins
1 milliard d'euros en 2019 donc nous
allons accentuer les efforts que nous
faisons euh sur nos charges
opérationnelles cependant je voudrais
souligner que comme nous l'avons euh
partagé avec les représentants du
personnel en début d'année nous serons
amenés et c'est assez logique à ne pas
remplacer tous les départs à la retraite
à développer la mobilité à cibler nos
recrutement sur les métiers en tension
et sur les métiers au cœur de la
stratégie cap 2030 deedf par exemple
dans les métiers du numérique mais cette
évolution de l'emploi a été anticipée
puisque avec un souci d'organiser les
transfert de compéten entre les
générations qui partent à la retraite et
les générations qui rentrent dans
l'entreprise nous avons anticipé de
nombreux recrutements en début de la
décennie de la décennie 2010 afin
justement de faire d'organiser bien
cette transmission de compétences avec
beaucoup de de dépenses de formation et
donc comme je l'ai
annoncé donc il y a quelques jours nous
allons diminuer les effectifs de DF dans
le cadre des trajectoires que nous
avions partagé avec le CCE en janvier
dernier et non pas au-delà et je coupe
ainsi cours à des rumeurs que nous
allions renforcer ces baisses
d'effectifs il y aura celle qui étaiit
prévu en début d'année mais nous ne
prévoyons pas en tout cas nous ne
prévoyons pas aujourd'hui d'aller
d'aller plus loin 3ème élément de notre
plan pour sécuriser notre trajectoire
financière un plan de cession d'actifs
ce plan vise de à céder des actifs pour
environ 10 milliards d'euros à l'horizon
2020 en consacr
pardon en concentrant le périmètre de DF
sur nos actifs clés le plan de session
inclut des participations minoritaires
il inclut des actifs de production
thermique hors de France et il inclut
aussi la concrétisation d'un chantier
que les les les deux ministres de Bery
ont également annoncé en début en fin de
semaine dernière le chantier de
l'évolution du capital de RTE dont
aujourd'hui DF détient 100 % du capital
sans pouvoir assurer une gouvernance
normale il y aura des orientations
stratégiques que le directoire de RTE
est en train de préparer nous aurons à
inscrire l'évolution du capital de RTE
dans ses orientations
stratégiques enfin la trajectoire
financière sécurisé deedf inclut un rôle
essentiel de l'État l'État en tant
qu'actionnaire et l'État en tant que
régulateur de du secteur vous l'avez dit
Monsieur le le président
EDF a fait part au conseil
d'administration de son intention de
proposé sur les années 2016 et 2017 une
option de versement des dividendes en
action et l'État a indiqué qu'il
retiendra cette option comme il l'a déjà
fait en 2015 puisque sur l'exercice 2015
le dividende que que l'État tire de DF
l'État le touche en titre et non pas en
cash donc cet argent 1 milillard 8
environ sur l'exercice 2015 reste dans
l'entreprise pour renforcer nos fonds
propres et améliorer notre équilibre
bilanciel
d'autre part EDF soumettra à son conseil
d'administration d'ici la clôture des
comptes 2016 et sous réserve des
conditions de marché un projet
d'augmentation de capital d'environ 4
milliards d'euros et l'État a indiqué
qu'il souscrira à cette augmentation de
capital à la hauteur de 3 milliards
d'euros donc vous voyez que par ces deux
mesures cell sur le dividende et celle
sur l'augmentation de capital l'État
actionnaire l'état investisseur avisé
accompagnera le groupe EDF dans cette
période d'investissement stratégique
mais l'État est aussi régulateur et je
voudrais terminer cette présentation en
vous disant quelques mots sur le besoins
indispensable que nous avons d'adapter
le modèle de
marché le modèle de marché actuel n'est
n'est pas durable tous les énergéticiens
européens sont en grande difficulté et
comme je le disais au début de mon
intervention EDF est plutôt parmi les
bien pant des électrices des
énergéticiens
européens aucun investiss aujourd'hui ne
se réalise sur le territoire européen
s'il n'est pas subventionné les prix de
marché ne permettent de justifier
d'aucun investissement il faut qu'il y
ait des interventions du régulateur pour
que les investissements notamment en
matière d'énergie renouvelable se se
fasse une évolution est donc nécessaire
du modèle de marché car la
régulation systématique des
investissements ne peut pas être la
seule réponse à la mise en concurrence
qui a été décidé il y aain ant 20 ans
des services de fourniture d'électricité
et d'ailleurs aussi de gaz le la
première nécessité c'est de donner un
prix minimum au carbone pour la
production d'électricité certains pays
comme le Royaume-Uni ou la Suède l'ont
déjà fait président de la République a
déclaré à la conférence environnementale
je crois que ça a été repris par la
ministre de l'environnement de l'énergie
et de la mer hier et à nouveau ce matin
président de la République a décidé
d'une démarche unilatérale de la France
je crois qu'il a même insister sur le
mot unilatéral pour fixer un prix
plancher du CO2 afin d'entraîner
d'autres pays avec nous je crois que
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour la planète
mais aussi pour notre industrie et pour
notre
groupe on voit que dans certains pays
voisins il continue à se faire de
nouveau de nouveaux investissements dans
des centrales au charbon ou au
ligit investissements qui sont fortement
polluants générateurs de particules et
générateurs de gaz à effet de
serre et ceci doit interpeller sur la
cohérence qu'il y a entre les objectifs
qui sont affichés et les politiques qui
sont réellement mis en place nous
considérons qu'un prix de 30 à 40 € la
tonne permettrait de remettre au bon
endroit dans l'ordre de mérite les
moyens de production en fonction de
leurs émissions et notamment de faire
passer les centrales au gaz devant les
centrales au
charbon nous souhaitons aussi que soit
reconnue la valeur des capacités de
production nécessaire à la sécurité
d'approvisionnement c'est ce qu'on
appelle les les le marché de capacité je
voudrais vous dire que d'après nos
analyses en cas de grand froid durable
heureusement ça n'a pas été le cas en
2016 pas plus qu'en 2015 ou 2014 mais
nous avions eu en 2012 une longue
période de grand froid qui touchait
l'essentiel de l'Europe de l'Ouest et
nous pensons que tel que le marché est
organisé aujourd'hui et va s'organiser
nous ne pouvons pas garantir c'est
l'analyse de DF il y a aussi l'analyse
de RTE bien évidemment qui est en charge
de ce sujet mais l'analyse de DF c'est
que nous ne pouvons pas garantir
l'absence de blackout au vu des
fermetures de centrales non rentables
que tous les électriciens mettent en
œuvre dans ces marchés avec des prix
aussi déprimé le mécanisme de capacité
est donc nécessaire si on veut en
permanence fournir l'électricité à tous
les clients en cas de longue période de
grand froid enfin il faut aussi créer un
cadre régulatoire qui permettra que de
nouveaux investissements soient décidés
fondés sur des prix de marché puisque
comme je le disais tous les
investissements sont payés par une
garantie de prix de vente c'est-à-dire
par l'augmentation de la facture des
clients final dès aujourd'hui et ce
mécanisme n'est évidemment pas durable
en conclusion avant de répondre à vos
questions et je répondrai monsieur le
Président à vos questions plus précises
sur inleay point si vous le voulez bien
tout à l'heure en conclusion nous sommes
un un tournant en 70 ans puisque nous
avons fêté il y a quelques jours les 70
ans de DF nous avons construit pour la
collectivité nationale un parc de
production capable d'alimenter tous nos
clients de manière efficace en
électricité mais nous vivons une
transition énergétique une transition
numérique la définition de nouveaux
modèles de marché décentralisés et c'est
une nouvelle page qui va s'écrire pour
l'histoire du groupe EDF mon rôle c'est
de m'assurer que DF puisse poursuivre sa
mission nous sommes une grande
entreprise au service du public nous
sommes l'entreprise de servic publics
qui recueille le plus d'adhésion des
Français nous devons encore nous ancrer
davantage dans les territoires et nous
devons participer activement à la
réponse que chacun attend en matière
d'enjeux climatique en matière de climat
sont des enjeux qui se posent à la
planète nous avons donc une stratégie et
je dirais que la trajectoire financière
que j'ai pu annoncer la semaine dernière
me permet de dire que nous avons aussi
désormais les moyens de remplir notre
mission et de tenir nos promesses voilà
monsieur le Président ce que je voulais
vous dire à titre préliminaire j'ai
peut-être été un peu long et et je m'en
excuse et puis je vais maintenant
répondre à vos questions merci monsieur
le Président je suis certain que vous
avez d'ailleurs répondu à l'avance à
certaines des questions qui peuvent être
posées qui néanmoins vont être peut-être
reformulé alors je rappelle les règles 2
minutes j'ai quelqu'un à côté de moi qui
chrono chrono je crois que si on veut
tenir dans un temps qui soit compatible
avec nos différentes
contraintes il est absolument
indispensable alors
alternativement entre les différents
groupes donc tout d'abord Ladislas
fatovski ensuite roland Courteau et un
intermède Maurice Vincent qui est membre
de la commission des finances et
rapporteur spécial de l'agence
participation de l'État lui aussi 2
minutes ah il aura 2 minutes aussi mais
c'est déjà bien 2 minutes n'est-ce pas
bien allez
Laski merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président concernant vos
investissements j'ai bien retenu vos
chiffres vous les avez pas tous annoncer
d'ailleurs in point 16 milliards je ne
sais pas combien votre charge combien la
charge de votre partenaire chinois grand
carénage vous nous avez dit 51 milliards
je pensais que le chiffre en interne
chez vous était déjà à 55
milliards vous n'avez pas rappelé mais
racheter l'activité nucléaire d'Areva
c'est 2,5 milliards enfin il y a un
chiffre que vous n'avez pas donné c'est
l'état de votre dette actuelle vous êtes
à
37,3
milliards alors je suis ravi pour vous
que l'État actionnaire est accepté de
vous suivre dans une augmentation de
capital à hauteur de 3 milliards
l'addition n'y est pas même si certains
investissements comme les 51 milliards
du grand carénage c'est d'ici 2025 moi
je vous pose une question très simple
que je vous ai déjà posé une fois vous
prenez bien un partenaire pour Inle
point un partenaire chinois pourquoi
est-ce que dans cette facture colossal
du grand carénage vous ne prenez pas des
partenaires même français il y a déjà
CIN centrales nucléaires françaises où
vous n'êtes pas propriétaire à 100 % une
partie du ces centrales appartiennent à
des partenaires privé pourquoi pour
alléger votre dette vous n'ouvrez pas
une partie du capital pour le la
rénovation de vos réacteurs c'était ma
première question si j'ai le temps ma
deuxième renouvelable le renouvelable
vous avez bien dit que vous seriez
présent moi je vous rappelle ce que
vient d'annoncer le le Danemark je
prends exprès pour une fois pas
l'Allemagne un exemple le Danemark 50 %
de la production d'électricité vient de
l'éolien cri cri de toutes les
entreprises les entreprises danoises
paient leur électricité trois fois plus
cher que les entreprises françaises
est-ce que vous croyez pas qu'il faut
mettre un certain merci merci la parole
est à Roland Courteau ensuite Maurice
Vincent merci monsieur le Président oui
concernant la la décision de reporter de
quelques mois in point et de consulter
le ce je dis elle est la bienvenue mais
selon moi le bon report devra être de 2
ou 3 ans il semblerait un effet très
risqué de lancer l'opération dès
maintenant c'est aussi notamment laave
des syndicats et il est largement
partagé entendons-nous bien il ne s'agit
pas de renoncer mais de reporter le
projet pour mieux pour mieux assurer sa
réussite le lancer dè maintenant ne
serait-il pas faire prendre à EDF un
risque existentielle et je pèse bien mes
mots conjoncture dégradée euh contexte
industriel qui n'est pas favorable
situation financière de DF préoccupante
achat d'arant grand carénage euh
modification du schéma de participation
et baisse de la participation des
Chinois question allez-vous persister ou
bien reporter la décision de 3 ans quant
à l'argument selon lequel si nous
n'engagions pas l'opération
immédiatement le Royaume-Uni pourrait se
tourner vers d'autres concurrents
personnellement moi je n'y crois pas
d'abord parce que seul le Pr est
certifié par l'Autorité de sûreté
britannique ensuite seul EDF possède les
terrains préparés et l'autorisation de
construire donc il faudrait plusieurs
années à tout autre projet concurrent
n'y a-t-il pas monsieur le Président
d'autres priorités immédiates que inclle
point et enfin concernant l'Europe
quelle est véritablement votre stratégie
vous soullignez par ailleurs que vous
investissez beaucoup dans les énergies
renouvelables mais dans le même temps on
observe des ventes d'actifs d'énergies
renouvelable pourtant rentable et
parallèlement le groupe prend des
engagements dans de nouveaux projets
alors pouvez-vous nous
expliquer bien je remercie le président
courte
euh qui n'a pas consommé son temps euh
la parole je peux continuer alors est à
Maurice c'est un encouragement limité la
parole est à Maurice Vincent ensuite à
brudeau sidau
oui merci monsieur le Président merci de
m'accueillir dans dans votre commission
monsieur le Président moi je voudrais
poser trois questions rapidement
concernant la dette qui est une question
importante 37 milliards cela a été dit
fin 2015 quel est le quelles sont vos
perspectives dans votre plan financier à
moyen terme comment la voyez-vous
évoluer puisqu'elle a quand même
augmenté de 8 % entre 2014 et 2015 la
deuxième question c'est sur les ventes
d'actifs 10 milliards sont annoncés j'ai
pu lire dans la presse que sur ces 10
milliards 6 milliards seraient réalisé
était envisagé en tout cas sur 2016
est-ce que vous confirmez ce chiffre ou
ou pas et puis pour Inle point qui estid
une question importante sur il y a un
engagement sur les prix est-ce qu'il y a
un engagement sur les quantités acheté
par le
Royaume-Uni je vous remercie bien merci
la parole est à Bruno sidau ensuite à
Franck
monteger merci monsieur le Président ma
question est très
simple question est très simple il est
question de plus en plus j'entendais
encore madame la ministre de
l'Environnement ce matin à la radio nous
dire que flamandville allait être fermé
que fin
les fa
fa ces mouvements divers sont pris sur
le temps de parole de Bruno Sido c'est
très court fait donc fin 2016 les
décisions devraent être prises et cetera
vous avez fait des gros travaux en fait
puisque les deux tranches sont été
rénovées et ma question est toute simple
est-ce que vous allez être
indemnisé de de ces travaux parce que
finalement soit vous auriez pu ne pas
les faire et fermer plus tôt et puisque
vous les avez fait que vous pensez
devoir les amortir je sais pas combien
de temps vous nous le direz d'ailleurs
allez-vous être indemnisé ça c'est la
première question et comment allons-nous
indemniser les Suisses et les Allemands
qui sont copropriétaire de cette
centrale bien merci Bruno sidau la
parole est à Franck monteger ensuite à
sopie prima mais merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président
Lévi pour votre exposé un regard
rétrospectif sur les 15 dernières années
nous amène à constater que DF évolue
dans le cadre d'un processus de
libéralisation impensé impensé par
l'État et les gouvernement qui sont
succédés comme par les dirigeants de
l'entreprise la situation extrêmement
préoccupante d'aujourd'hui nous conforte
dans ce sentiment qu'il n'y a pas de
vision pas de stratégie suffisamment
claire et partagée le bradage du
patrimoine public qui illustre une
nouvelle fois sous l'impulsion de
Bruxelles l'injonction de libéralisation
de la production hydraulique atteste
également du processus de dépessage
progressif d'un des plus grands
énergéticiens au monde dans ce même
secteur on a connu d'autres entreprises
et pas des moindres qui ont disparu au
terme de prise de décision qui sont
avéré au final hasardeuses EDF n'est pas
à l'abri et les grands pojets don vous
avez parlé qui sont autant de prises de
risque inclep en fait partie pourrait
accentuer ce processus pour certains
d'entre eux c'est cela qu'il faut éviter
en ant aux objectifs qui ont présidé il
y a 70 ans à la nationalisation des
entreprises du secteur de l'énergie de
l'époque indépendance énergétique de la
France et exportation égalité d'accès à
une électricité de qualité à des coûts
maîtrisés pour tous et sur tout le
territoire c'est la péréquation
tarifaire peu de sollicitation
financière de l'État sur longue période
modèle social exemplaire qui n'a pas peu
contribué au réussite depuis 1945 tels
ont été les ingrédients de la réussite
et en définitive EDF a contribué de
façon essentielle majeure à la
compétitivité de notre économie à la
souveraineté nationale de la France et à
son rayonnement international le cap
industriel doit rester celui-là tout en
intégrant les enjeux de la transition
énergétique son respect dans la durée
suppose qu'État et gouvernement s'oppose
par tout moyen à la financiérisation des
marchés de l'énergie vous avez monsieur
le Président évoqué ce point en parlant
du modèle de marché actuel qui n'est pas
durable là se situe la question
politique majeure dont la réponse
orientera le devenir de DF elle se tout
autant au niveau européen que national
la stratégie industrielle de DF doit en
être la déclinaison au premier au
bénéfice premier nous l'oublions pas des
consommateurs et de nos entreprises
merci merci Franck monteger la parole
est à Sophie prima et ensuite à Martial
Bourquin merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président après ces
questions très stratégiques moi je
voudrais terre terre à terre vous avez
décidé de fermer la centrale à fou de
Porcheville avec notamment la fermeture
de deux génér ur dès 2017 alors que la
décision de de fermeture était
2023 à l'origine je comprends les
caractéristiques financières
probablement très lourdes de ce site
j'ai quand même levé l'oreille tout à
l'heure quand vous avez parlé du marché
de capacité notamment pour faire face au
grand froid durable puisque cette
centrale n'était utilisée que dans ce
cas-là et que effectivement contenu de
la météo des deux dernières années elle
n'a pas été utilisée donc je comprends
la charge financière mais je comprends
aussi le rôle de cette centrale de
porscheville donc mes questions sert là
aussi assez pragmatiques je voulais
savoir quel était le poids en fait de
cette centrale euh de sécurité
finalement par rapport au blackout que
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure le poids
financier de cette centrale dans vos
résultats quels seront comment vont être
traités les les 200 employés EDF qui
travaillent sur ce site de porscheville
quelles actions avez-vous entreprise ou
pensez-vous entreprendre sur les très
nombreux prestataires de services qui
travaillent pour cette centrale il y en
a dans l'IND vallée de la scinene 130 de
dénombré et puis ensuite en tant qu'élu
aussi de ce territoire queles sont les
pistes de reconversion de ce site de 90
hectares aux portes du port de Limet que
vous envisagez y compris éventuellement
dans la transition énergétique avez-vous
des projets dans ce sens merci beaucoup
bien merci Sophie prima la parole est à
Martial Bourquin ensuite Daniel Dubois
merci monsieur le Président de de cet
exposé trois questions simples vous
n'avez pas abordé la question des
déchets et du démantelllement des
centrales euh pouvez-vous l'aborder euh
dans les réponses aux questions avec
euh le prix que ça représente parce que
il y a eu des articles dans le monde et
dans la presse économique nous disant
que les prix pourraient exploser sur ces
questions deuxème chose euh 3500 postes
supprimés est-ce que ça sera au
détriment de la présence
territorial vous savez que la présence
territoriale de ce grand énergéticien
qui est EDF est une question essentielle
et euh pouvez-vous nous préciser je
trouve que la note est salée euh et
est-ce qu'il est possible de revenir en
arrière sur ces suppressions d'emploi 3è
question recherche fondamentale et
appliquée vous avez parlé beaucoup du
nucléaire des énergies renouvelables
est-ce que la recherche continue sur
l'hydrogène
sur les énergies de demain avec la
question du numérique on sait qu'il va y
avoir de véritables révolutions dans le
matière de l'énergie est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en parler plus précisément
merci bien merci Marcial Bourquin la
parole est
à Daniel Dubois et ensuite à Delphine
bataille merci
président monsieur le Président moi j'ai
une seule question vous nous avez
précisé que vous aviez bâti un plan
stratégique à 2030
euh vous avez une production
d'électricité qui est à 75 % nucléaire
je ne peux imaginer que vous ayez bâti
ce plan sans naturellement penser les
fermetures
is d'un certain nombre de central donc
combien et avez-vous des assurances de
l'État ouais sur ce nombre de
fermeture bien merci Daniel Dubois la
parole est donc à Delphine bataille et
ensuite à abeth Lamur merci monsieur le
président parmi les actions de
désendettement de DF annoncé un plan de
session à hauteur de 10 milliards
d'euros dont 50 % de RTE pour 3
milliards et demi et l'évolution après
le dernier conseil d'administration fait
apparaître une part de RTE avant 2016 je
voudrais savoir si vous NZ si vous
pouvez pardon nous préciser maintenant à
quoi correspond cette part ainsi que son
montant vous avez également évoqué un
plan plan d'économie qui augmente la
réduction des charges opérationnelles à
1 milliard d'euros au lieu des 700
millions initialement prévu est-ce que
vous pouvez nous indiquer les modalités
et le calendrier de ce plan vous
comprendrez nos inquiétudes sur la
solidité financière de DF qui aura aussi
à supporter le le poids d'Areva vous
avez évoquer un certain nombre de
charges à venir et je voudrais pour ma
part revenir sur 6Go puisque le dernier
euh devis officiel prévoit un
renchérissement euh du cûp ce sont 25
milliards d'euros pour ODF je voudrais
savoir comment vous avez prévu de
répondre en terme d'échéencier et quel
sera le montant du provisionnement
immédiat enfin comment envisagez-vous
les perspectives en terme de coût de
l'énergie comptenu aujourd'hui du niveau
des prix et dans un contexte où il est
difficile de démontrer la per pertinance
du nucléaire par rapport au prix des
autres énergies par exemple le baril du
pétrole est-ce que vous pensez que la
notion de durée est suffisamment prise
en compte dans nos débats publics je
m'explique aujourd'hui l'objectif de la
loi qui fixe à 50 % la part du nucléaire
dans la production d'électricité en
moins de 10 ans semble illusoire pour
beaucoup d'entre nous en raison de cette
durée parfois mal apprécié et aussi au
regard de la durée de vie des centrales
quel est votre avis sur la prolongation
en terme de durée de vie des C merci
merci Delphine bataille la parole éit
Élisabeth Lamur ensuite Yannick
vugrenard merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président j'aurais une
question qui porte sur
l'hydraulique vous avez dit que vous
souhaitiez optimiser votre potentiel
hydraulique et en effet DF gère je crois
80 %
du du parc hydraulique de de notre pays
or vous savez que la Commission
européenne s'impatiente sur la mise en
concurrence des concessions
hydro-électriques je ne sais pas si les
appels d'offre ont été lancés en tout
cas c'est quelque chose qui dure depuis
2008 lorsque les appels d'offres seront
là est-ce que EDF entend être
candidate pour la gestion de ces des
concessions qu'elle qu'elle exploite
aujourd'hui et puis dans le prolongement
une question concernant la redevance
hydraulique qui a donc été mise en place
en 2006 elle est importante parce
qu'elle représente 24 ou 25 % du du
chiffre d'affaires
euh et il semblerait que EDF ne s'acquit
pas de cette redevance et que seul la
CNR la compagnie nationale du rô l' fait
or ce sont des montants qui sont
extrêmement importants tant pour l'État
que pour les collectivités puisque c'est
un partage à 5050 et cela représente
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
est-ce que vous pouvez nous répondre sur
ce point je vous remercie
merci Elisabeth Lamur la parole à
yanrenard ensuite Philippe Leroi oui
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur levide la
présentation particulièrement complète
et détaillée que vous nous avez faite
qui n permet d'avoir des informations
très très très très importante vous
l'avez souligné EDF est exemplaire dans
dans beaucoup de domaines et d'abord je
pense que le fait
queedf été créé voici 70 ans vous l'avez
rappelé par le Conseil National de la
Résistance
le fait que la participation de l'État
soit à hauteur de 85 % c'est la
conséquence aujourd'hui c'estelle cause
probablement aujourd'hui du fait que
notre indépendance nationale énergétique
est préservée le la conséquence la cause
également le le le le fait que le prix
de de de l'électricité est moins
important en France qu'ailleurs vous
l'avez souligné et pour le particulier
et pour nos entreprises cependant il y a
nous sommes à un tournant vous l'avez
souligné vous êtes montré rassurant dans
le détail également sur le contrat avec
in Inle
point
cependant le fait d'être assassurant
n'empêche pas d'avoir aussi un certain
nombre d'inquiétude pourquoi parce que
flamandville le père de flamandville à
plusieurs reprises a vu une augmentation
très forte de son coût et vous nous avez
annoncé que cela devrait être misise en
œuvre le 4e trimestre 2018 2018 pardon
quen serait-il s'il y avait d'une part
prolongation de cette mise en uvre de
flamandville et d'autre part si c'était
encore plus coûteux quellees conséquen
cela pourrait avoir sur l'investissement
éventuel de en Angleterre il ne faudrait
pas en effet que le père de de
flamandville devienne en quelque sorte
si je puis m'exprimer ainsi le Concorde
de l'énergie française et pour cela il
nous faut beaucoup de de prudence enfin
deuxème question euh sur le stockage de
l'énergie on en parle souvent je crois
que c'est l'alpha et et l'oméga de de
l'énergie de demain y a-t-il des
recherches collaboratives avec
l'ensemble des pays de l'Union
européenne merci Yannick vugrenard la
parole est à Philippe Leroi et ensuite à
Joë Labé
oui ma première question c'est la même
que celle de
yanrenard pourquoi ne pas
attendre la certitude de terminer
flamandville avec une sécurité
financière sur le plan des
essais des c'estes techniques en cours
pourquoi ne pas attendre tout cela ça
serait peut-être prudent dans le cadre
d'une stratégie que je partage
d'ailleurs EDF si on veut rester sur le
marché mondial dans la construction des
centrales nucléairirees il faut espérer
que Flam enville puisse marcher mais on
en est pas encore s donc pourquoi ne pas
attendre un peu par prudence deuxème
question vous n'avez pas parlé des
énergies renouvelables mais je suis
assez heureux que vous ne parliez pas de
la biomasse EDF ne semble pas avoir de
projet dans la la biomasse et c'est et
c'est assez heureux dans la mesure où
votre confrère Eon s'est lancé dans un
projet
pharaonique à Tarascon si j'ai bonne
mémoire
ou à Gardane est en train de de détruire
bien des espoirs pour la filière bois
donc cuid de la biomasse et merci
peut-être de ne pas en parler ou de ne
pas en faire trisè question
euh le
le grand carénage EDF a-t-il bien
imaginé l'association de de l'économie
locale le développement local à
l'occasion des chantiers de grand
carénage à l'image de ce qui a été fait
pour les stratégies grands chantier
quand on construisait les les centrales
je sais que chez moi DF a largement
contribué au développement d'entreprise
locale au moment de la construction de
catnom et quid du carénage bien merci
Philippe Leroi la parole est à Joë Labé
ensuite Gérard bailli oui merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Président
Lévi merci d'abord de de de votre exposé
de venir vous exposer je vous trouve
très serein étant donné les enjeux mais
je crois que dans votre position vous
vous devez d'être serein beaucoup de
questionnements quand même n'oublions
pas n'oublions pas que on est au
lendemain de l'anniversaire de de la
terrible catastrophe de Tchernobyl d'une
part alors on a parlé démentantellement
euh notre collègue martial burquin vous
Vous annoncez à juste titre qu'on
produit actuellement une électricité
abondante et au moins cher de de par
rapport par rapport à nos voisins pour
ma part et pour notre part nous estimons
que le prisionnement pour les les futur
démantellement quels que soient les
délais successifs qu'on qu'on va devoir
financer euh parlez-nous un petit peu
desprovisionnement et des garanties que
vous avez sur le fait que c'est c'est
ces démantellement successifs je veux
parler à 10 20 30 ans ça va commencer
avant 10 ans d'ailleurs pour les
premières d'une part d'autre part
derrière cela l'avenir enfin votre
société a un avenir aussi dans le
démantelllement de par un certain
savoir-faire et une véritable économie
dans le démantelllement sur le
territoire français comme à l'étranger
si vous voulez nous donner quelques
précisions un deuxième point qui
pourrait paraître plus léger mais qui a
son importance on avait longuement débat
sur les ZNI les zones non
interconnectées avec très peu d'enjeux
les petites îles notamment à moins de
20000 à moins de 2000 clients donc je
sais que EDF était intervenu pour que
pour que la majorité obtenue ne ne
puisse pas être renouvelé alors pour le
moment puisque ces zones non
interconnectées n'ont pas de statut
particulier est-ce que vous seriez à
même de déléguer à de petits opérateurs
pour mettre en place véritablement en
bénéficiant de la CSPE des projets
collaboratifs des projets innovants des
projets expérimentaux dont on aura
besoin au plan national et aussi au plan
international mer Labé la parole est à
Gérard baayli ensuite Jean-Pierre bzino
oui en constat les accidents climatiques
se font de plus en plus nombreux je
pense ces dernières décennies voir ces
dernières années tempête coup de vent
neige orage et aujourd'hui on sait que
on plus d'électricité toute la vie
économique que s'arrête c'est peut-être
encore plus important qu'hier d'avoir
des dépanages rapides alors une
inquiétude d'abord qu'on ne diminue pas
bien c'est les gens qui font les
réparations pour je crois que M que le
terrain en a besoin et très rapidement
c'est un souhait que que je voudrais que
j'aimis en cet instant deè 2uxème
question aussi c'est par
rapport des bruits qui on été cru que on
il y aurait les effacements des jours de
pointe le JP pourriez-vous nous rassurer
là dessus et pourir dédire parce que je
sais que dans secteur où je suisement
l'agriculture on a beaucoup de séchagant
grand l'été AC beaucoup à le JP et qu'à
ce moment-là l'hiver font des économies
ces jours-là ne consomment pas
d'électricité donc c'est important en
terme aussi de de ma région de séchage
d'été où on a beaucoup besoin d'énergie
au moment où il y en a pas besoin
ailleurs alors est-ce que l' JP va se
poursuivre troisème chose vous avvez
parlé d'Ikea est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner plus de précision on l'avz juste
évoqué et 4e et dernière euh la Bour
aujourd'hui je crois que c'est à 12 € au
lieu que c'était à 32 est-ce quelles
sont les incidences est-ce qu'il va pas
y avoir un manque de confiance aussi des
différentes personnes est-ce que ça peut
poser des problèmes bien entendu sur
quelles sont les répercussions qui peut
y avoir cette diminution importante des
cours de bourse ETF bien merci Gérard la
parole est à Jean-Pierre bovin ensuite
Daniel
GRM merci messieurs les
présidentsan monug l' évoqué ok je à mon
tour juste un mot sur les 70 ans de DF
je je ne suis pas certain que ils
doivent être très peu mais parmi ceux
qui ont participé à la libération à la
création de cette grande entreprise qui
était EDF GDF ils soient très fier de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui et et de de de
ce qu'on a fait de cette entreprise je
veux le dire parce que effectivement on
est à l'inverse de ce qui était leur
démarche du bien commun on a beaucoup
oup parlé vous nous avez beaucoup parlé
monsieur le Président Levi de stratégie
de trajectoire financière moins de
stratégie industrielle et je pense qu'il
serait utile que vous nous précisiez un
certain nombre de choses de ce point de
vue et en particulier vous avez évoqué
les économies qui vont passer de 700
millions à 1
milliard et donc des des suppressions
d'emploi hein puisque le fait de non de
ne pas renouveler des des départs c'est
sont des suppressions d'emploi quelle
est la
répartition si vous l'avez des des
suppressions d'emploi parce que moi j'ai
une inquiétude en particulier sur les
emplois qui concernent la recherche et
le développement mais aussi la
production la production directe et puis
une dernière chose votre prédécesseur
monsieur progliot en 2014 nous déclara
que cette grande loi qu'on appelle la
loi nom oblige EDF av vendre un/4 de sa
production en dessous le prix de revient
à ses concurrents qu'en est-il
aujourd'hui puisque de fait ça
aboutissait à subventionner des
concurrents
deedf bien merci Jean-Pierre bzinot la
parole est à Daniel grber ensuite à l'in
Duran
oui merci président euh une première
remarque je voudrais monsieur le
Président vous remercier de de votre
propos parce qu'il contribue rapporter
de la confiance et lorsqu'on est dans le
champ concurrentiel il est vraiment
important d'avoir cette
confiance j'ai que deux questions
simples la première vous avez pas du
tout abordé le prix du
baril qui d'après le monde pétrolier
s'installe quand même dans des niveaux
très bas en terme de concurrence c'est
un questionnement et ma deuxième
question c'est ma curiosité d'en savoir
plus sur votre stratégie sur
RTE on connaît l'échec de la SNCF
de RFF on connaît l'importance et la
réussite qui a été EDF sur l'ensemble du
territoire et effectivement quand je
j'entends votre propos je voudrais en
savoir un peu plus merci merci Dan
gréier la parole est à alin durant
ensuite Anne Catherine oisier merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président LVI vous avez évoqué dans vos
propos vos ambitions fortes je cite en
matière d'énergie renouvelable et
l'hydroélectricité fait partie de ces
énergies donc je voudrais revenir sur
les concession hydroélectrique et plus
particulièrement sur la mise en demeure
faite à la France par l'Union européenne
le 22 octobre dernier afin d'ouvrir la
les concessions hydroélectrique à la
concurrence au moment de le
renouvellement alors certes si l'envoie
d'une lettre de mise en demeure ne
préjuge pas de la conclusion finale de
la procédure par contre la procédure
permet à la commission d'entamer un
dialogue actif avec les autorités don
monsieur le Président pouvez-vous nous
préciser où en sont aujourd'hui ces
discussions entre la commission l'État
et et votre entreprise et toujours sur
le même sujet euh au mois d'août dernier
dans la loi de transition énergétique un
nouveau dispositif d'ouverture des
concessions permet également de
repousser ces effchances dans la mesure
où des travaux importants seront pris
seront entrepris dans les ouvrages
compte tenu du contexte et et des zones
de turbulence qui ont été rappelé depuis
le début et que traverse votre
entreprise euh vous prévoyez de réduire
vos les investissements et de les
ramener à 10 milliards contre 15
aujourd'hui pouvez-vous nous préciser
monsieur le Président où iront vos
priorités est-ce que les 435 centrales
hydroélectriques et les 622 barrages que
contre que contre notre pays seront
impactés par ces baisses ce sont des
interrogations en tout cas qui
préoccupent les habitants de de nos
vallée qui vivent avec depuis très
longtemps avec l'hydroélectricité qui
reste une filière d'excellence merci
Alain Durand Catherine oisier a la
parole et ensuite Serge Larché oui merci
président donc ma question va à peu près
dans dans le même sens à savoir quelle
est votre stratégie en en matière de
développement des des ressources de
production durable et plus précisément
donc quelles sont les perspectives
d'évolution dans la répartition des des
différentes énergies renouvelables au
sein de votre production bien merci Anne
Catherine noisier Serge Larcher a la
parole et ensuite Dominique Estrosi
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président lesv vous avez fait part de
votre volonté de développer des
solutions décentralisées c'est notre
cadre là que je voudrais vous poser une
question concernant euh le projet de
construction d'une centrale gé thmique
dans l'île de la de la de la Dominique
projet à la fois par les deux conseil
par le Conseil Régional de la Martinique
conseil régional de la Guadeloupe je
cite je rappelle que Dominique ça situe
entre les deux îles et nous dépendons
fortement aujourd'hui vous savez bien de
des énergies fossiles et ce quievient
que à faire ce qui fait que l'énergie
coûte très cher dans ces îles qui sont
non
connectées bien merci sergech la parole
est à Dominique est ensuite à ivrom oui
merci monsieur le Président vous nous
avez dit que vous aviez anticipé de
nombreux
recrutements au début de la décennie de
l'année 2010 je voudrais me référer à un
rapport de la Cour des comptes de mars
2016 qui soulligne que les projets
industriels desdf dans le nucléaire
nécessiteront 110000 recrutements d'ici
2020 en emploi direct et indirect dont
70000 emplois de niveau Bac pro à bac +
3 alors qu'on sait que les 2/ers des des
entreprises de la filière ont beaucoup
de mal à recruter dans certains métiers
pense à la robinetterie tuyoterie
soudage bureau d'études et dans ce
rapport de la Cour des comptes il est
également écrit que vous avez aussi
identifié une faiblesse de la ressource
d'encadrement essentiellement compte
tenu des délé de formation qui sont
particulièrement longs est-ce que vous
pourriez nous préciser un peu plus votre
stratégie en matière
d'emploi bien merci domies Rovi la
parole est à yvrome oui très rapidement
monsieur le Président j'aimerais vous
l'avez évoqué partiellement connaître
votre stratégie par rapport à la
numérisation de la société nous sommes
en train d'examiner un texte sur la
République numérique je voudrais
connaître quelle est la stratégie d'EDF
par rapport aux objets connectés dont on
nous annonce des dizaines des dizaines
de milliards d'objets à l'intérieur de
nos habitations et également connaître
votre position par rapport aux
sollicitations nombreuses dont nous
sommes l'objet par rapport aux
électrosensibles sur le compteur
Linky merci la parole est à François
Calvet oui
moi je voudrais juste poser une question
pour savoir quel est l'état de
fonctionnement et la rentabilité des
interconnexions électriques notamment
avec l'Espagne avec la THT nouvelle que
vous avez fait passer depuis qui part de
l'ode et qui traverse les pyénées
orientales et qui va jusqu'à au Pertus
et comment comment ça ça se passe et
quel est les échanges avec l'Espagne S
sont
fructueux bien on a terminé avec ma
dernière question qui est en fait la
suivante concernant fait cela monsieur
le Président l'autorité de sûrté
nucléaire a accordé 10 ans
supplémentaires qui nous pousse à
au-delà de 2020 est-ce qu'il est
cohérent aujourd'hui de la part du
gouvernement de demander la fermeture de
réacteurs qui ont justement fait l'objet
d'une validation par l'autorité de sité
nucléaire quel serait l'impact financier
il y a un rapport parlementaire ENF de
la Assemblée nationale un rapport
bipartisan qui chiffre à 4 milliards
d'euros le montant de ce qui devrait
être versé au DF est-ce que vous pouvez
confirmer ce chiffre enfin en ce qui
concerne la réduction de la part du
nucléaire le gouvernement semble vouloir
diminuer dans les années qui viennent le
nombre de réacteurs en service alors je
vous demande pas de me donner la liste
des réacteurs qui seraient
euh désignés
mais quels sont selon vous les critères
qui pourrai être pris en compte est-ce
que notamment celui de l'âge du réacteur
enfin si vous autoriser concernant RTE
j'aimerais que vous soyez plus précis la
loi est très claire elle dit que RTE
doit être à 100 % publique alors est-ce
que par rapport à cette obligation vous
avez des information qui laisse à penser
qu'on sortirait de la sphère publique si
on ne sort pas bon est-ce que passer
d'une poche à l'autre euh sur le même
costume change beaucoup l'équilibre
financier de l'opération
voilà monsieur le Président euh vous
avez beaucoup de question je vous
félicite les uns et les autres y compris
mon intervention qui qui s'est tenu dans
le cadre que j'ai que j'ai que j'ai fixé
33 minutes et il y a eu 22
interventions
bien 22 interventions auxquelles je vais
essayer de répondre d'abord en vous
remerciant de de vos questions je suis
un peu confus parce qu'elles sont très
diverses et alors les rassembler en
elles sont diverses oui les rassembler
et essayer de donner une réponse un peu
construite ne va pas être facile donc je
vous prie à l'avance de de de m'excuser
si je n'arrive pas à à à à donner une
réponse complètement structuré en tout
cas peut-être je vais je vais commencer
par les sujets le président le noir
avait commencé par cela autour d'inkle
point
euh président Lenoir
et un un autre des des sénateurs ici
présents a en effet posé la question
d'abord de la garantie de volume hein
d'Inle point alors je voudrais dire que
nous sommes doublement garantis nous
sommes garantis sur le prix mais nous
sommes doublement garantis sur le volume
nous avons une première garantie qui est
dans le marché dans le mode de
fonctionnement du marché britannique
donc c'est une garantie générique sur la
priorité donnée au au aux installations
de base hein puisque le nucléaire bien
évidemment fonctionne en base et puis
nous avons une deuxième garantie sur nos
volumes qui est dans le contrat pour
différence que nous avons de cette
fois-ci de façon spécifique au projet
inclle point négocié avec le
gouvernement britannique et qui est à
l'intérieur donc de ce contrat pour
différence donc nous n'avons pas de
souci que nous arriverons non seulement
à produire
à vendre au prix qui a été convenu
contractualisé enfin qu' est dans le
projet que le contrat soit signé bientôt
mais aussi à écouler sur le marché nos
volumes parce que c'est un souci tout à
fait naturel la question que vous vous
posez nous nous l'étions posé nous avons
donc une une réponse en ce qui concerne
les les les autres sujets sur sur incle
point le partage des risques oui nous
avons deux actionnaires à par à par égal
enfin avec un niveau de risque à peu
près équivalent qui sont EDF pour les 2
tiers et les Chinois pour 1/ers et
d'ailleurs je répondrai sur les chiffres
du du sénateur poniatovski inclleay
point est est au total un chantier qui
va coûter environ allez ça dépend un
petit peu du du taux livre euro mais
mettons qu'il coûte environ 24 milliards
24 milliards d'euros les Chinois nos
partenaires de CGN vont en apporter le
tiers 8 milliards et nous nous allons
mettre en effet 16 milliards d'euros
mais ce projet a déjà commencé depuis
plusieurs années donc nous n'avons pas
devant nous la totalité des 24 milliards
d'euros à dépenser mais peut-être
avons-nous dépensé déjà 10 ou 15 % de de
de de cette somme alors nous avons en
effet prévu un partage des risques mais
dans la mesure où EDF est
le mettre d'ouvrage puisque nous sommes
à la fois celui qui va fournir le
réacteur et celui qui va l'exploiter à
travers cette filiale nous avons mis en
place des systèmes
incitatifs pour que le le le le EDF soit
un petit peu récompensé du travail qu'il
a déjà fait et EDF soit un peu pénalisé
s'il est en retard mais ces montants
sont tout à fait minimes ils n'ont rien
à voir avec le montant qu'il s'agit
d'investir donc le le le si si si les
choses se passe bien nous pourrions
investir un ou 2 % de moins euh par
rapport aux Chinois si les choses se
passent mal 1 ou 2 % de plus c'est juste
un mécanisme incitatif mais il est de de
de faible ampleur donc je réponds aussi
ainsi à la à la question sur sur sur le
partage de risque sur la durée de de
réalisation il est clair que c'est un
grand projet et que nous
avons mis toutes les chances de nos côté
de notre côté pour le réaliser au bon
moment et et notamment en tenant compte
de façon essentielle de des leçons que
nous apprenons chaque jour sur
Flamanville en particulier et et aussi
sur tan puisque nous avons des dizaines
de représentants de DF et d'Areva qui
sont présents aujourd'hui en Chine pour
la construction et aujourd'hui ce sont
plutôt les essais la construction à peu
près achevée de de taan donc nous
mettons toutes les chances de notre côté
je voudrais souligner puisque j'avais
j'avais des des des questions là-dessus
que le le les délais sont un sujet tout
à fait tout à fait essentiel notamment
Monsieur Philippe Leroi vous vous disiez
il faudrait attendre flamandville mais
c'est ce que nous avons fait puisque le
chantier d'incle point va commencer en
2019 la phase que nous lançons
aujourd'hui est une phase dans lequelle
nous lançons des constructions des
différents équipements qui sont les
mêmes qu'à qu'à flamandville sauf pour
la sauf pour la cuve et puis ce sont
surtout des phases d'études et des
phases propres au sitite d'inklep parce
que par exemple pour vous donner un
exemple le canal de Bristol dans lequel
nous allons aller chercher l'eau il a
des caractéristiques notamment l'eau est
assez boueuse qui nous oblige à faire
des travaux spécifiques sur incle point
et que nous n'avons pas à faire sur
flamandville ou dans le cô l'eau est
beaucoup plus pureil et donc les travaux
que nous avons à faire sont
essentiellement des études des travaux
de terrassement des travaux de
préparation de chantier et l'agencement
des choses fait que en décidant Inle
point maintenant le chantier de
construction du bâtiment nucléaire
d'incle point démarra quand nous aurons
terminé les essais de celui de
flamandville c'estàdire en 2019 et donc
nous avons aujourd'hui une une très
bonne continuité dans la gestion de nos
compétences si nous si nous retardons
comme certains le demandent le chantier
de de de Flamenville l'un des
inconvénients c'est que nous allons à
nouveau avoir une rupture dans les
chantiers puisque le chantier de
construction d'inkley point le premier
béton de sûrté donc la partie la plus
difficile he les les les l'enceinte de
de bâtiment nucléaire et toutes ces
constructions à l'intérieur du bâtiment
nucléaire sont retardé alors de 2 ans de
3 ans je ne sais pas peut-être jamais
non plus hein mais seront retardés par
rapport à la fin de de Flamanville donc
il faut voir que la décision que nous
voulons prendre aujourd'hui sur Inle
point ce se cale au niveau du calendrier
du mieux possible par rapport à
l'achèvement de de Flamanville et bien
sûr les équipes participent en
permanence les équipes de d'Inle point
et les équipes
de de Flamanville participent en
permanence les unes avec les autres à ce
qu'on appelle le retour le retour
d'expérience la durée de réalisation
mais nous nous sommes fixer des
objectifs à l'intérieur de ces objectifs
nous avons mis des provisions nous avons
prévu des aléas un chantier comme
celui-là on se contente pas de dire on
devrait faire tel jour ou telle semaine
telle tâche on fait l'addition et puis
voilà le planning non par définition en
tant que responsable industriel on met
des aléas est-ce que ces aléas sont trop
importants est-ce qu'ils sont justes
est-ce qu'ils sont insuffisant et bien
l'avenir le dira mais nous avons mis des
provisions financières des provisions de
délis en matière de d'Ala qui nous
semble respecter la meilleure
appréciation que l'on peut faire des
risques de dérapage et puis nous avons
aussi et nous l'avons fait dans le cadre
du conseil d'administration
communiquer les éléments financiers qui
conduisent à mesurer s'il y a encore des
aléas supplémentaires au-delà des aléas
qui sont déjà prévus et nous avons
démontré que la rentabilité du projet en
fait elle est à peine écornée par des
délais supplémentaires pourquoi parce
que la rentabilité du projet se fait par
les 35 ans de prix garanti et qu'un
décalage de prix de construction c'est
désagréable mais ça n bouleverse pas
cela ne modifie que légèrement
l'équilibre financier du projet ce qui
fait l'équilibre financier du projet
c'est les 35 ans de prix garanti et
c'est un point qui est donc tout à fait
tout à fait tout à fait essentiel je
voudrais peut-être parler maintenant des
des
sujets sur la programmation des
centrales nucléaires vous avez été
nombreux à m'en parler monsieur Dubois
le président le président Loir monsieur
Vaugrenard aussi un petit peu à travers
les
conséquences sur
flamandville
euh je je dirais que Monsieur Courteau
avait aussi un petit peu évoqué ce sujet
en parlant aussi de de de de Flamanville
je voudrais vous dire que les choses vu
de DF sont extrêmement claires la
représentation nationale a voté une
loi le gouvernement met en place les les
texte d'application et EDF
entreprise implanté en France applique
les lois de de la République la loi
prévoit la fermeture de fessonheim
lorsque Flam enville est mise en service
nous serons donc à fermer Fessenheim
lorsque flamonville sera mise en service
et le gouvern
a souhaité que le dispositif qui
conduira à cette fermeture qui est donc
à l'horizon de la fin 2018 he la mise en
service de de flamandville 3 fin 2018
que ce dispositif soit préparé et bouclé
si vous me permettez l'expression dès
cette année
2016 le gouvernement a demandé de
préparer les les les différentes étapes
dès cette année 2016 alors quelles sont
ces étapes et bien il y a l'étape
actuelle dans lequel nous nous nous
avons engagé depuis quelques semaines
Madame cgolen Royal a désigné il y a 5
ou 6 semaines un négociateur sur
l'indemnisation et l'étape actuelle
c'est que nous avons ouvert des
discussions entre DF et le négociateur
du ministère de l'Environnement nous
avons ouvert des discussions sur
l'indemnité en effet la
question est si je puis dire s'impose il
y a un préjudice subi par EDF du fait de
la privation qu'URA EDF lors de la
fermeture d' un outil nucléaire qui
comme certains l'ont souligné fonctionne
bien sur lequel l'Autorité de sûreté
nucléaire a
donné des des autorisations qui
dépassent la date à laquelle il est
prévu qu'il s'arrête de par la loi et
donc le préjudice qui est je crois
indiscutable nécessite d'être chiffré
ces discussions vont se poursuivre
j'imagine dans les jours et les semaines
qui viennent et puis lorsque la
l'indemnisation aura été discutée entre
l'État et et et EDF nous aurons à ce
moment-là à préparer l'approbation par
le conseil d'administration d'EDF de
cette convention entre l'État et et EDF
et à préparé ce que Madame Royal a a
annoncé c'est-à-dire le retrait
d'autorisation d'exploitation qu'elle
voudrait qu'elle a demandé euh pour le
président de la République je crois l'a
dit aussi à la à la conférence
environnementale lundi dernier il est
prévu que ceci soit fait au mois de
décembre donc nous nous inscrivons dans
un calendrier dans lequel nous discutons
actuellement de l'indemnisation et puis
dans une deuxième étape nous préparerons
l'approbation par le conseil
d'administration cette approbation
devant d'abord faire l'objet d'un examen
par les différentes instances
représentatives du personnel concerné
puisque il s'agit d'une décision qui a
des des conséquences social il n'y a pas
de doute et que donc il y aura de de de
notre part à préparer les réponses aux
questions que vont immanquablement se
poser les représentants du personnel
sur sur ce sujet
sur la suite des opérations et bien nous
nous avons aujourd'hui la partie
renouvelable de la PPE et EDF s'inscrit
clairement
dans
l'accélération de cette de ces
investissement en en
France
nous avons je va peut-être répondre
d'ailleurs à Monsieur courte en effet
une politique affirmée de construction
de nombreuses installation de nombreuses
infrastructures éoliennes ou Solair mais
aussi une politique de cession de
certains de ces actifs car pour des
raisons d'équilibre de notre bilan nous
ne gardons pas dans notre patrimoine la
totalité des fermes éoliennes ou des
fermes solaires que nous construisons
nous en vendons une partie à des
investisseurs qui ont un intérêt à
eux-mêmes à revendre ces produits
financiers très prévisibles euh à à
d'autres catégories d'épargnant et le
rôle de DF je crois qu'on peut
s'accorder là-dessus c'est plutôt de
construire pour nous tous pour la
planète de construire un maximum de
moyens d'énergie décboné d'électricité
décarbonée mais pas nécessairement dans
une période où nous avons vous l'avez
les uns et les autres souligné beaucoup
d'endettements pas nécessairement de
garder la totalité des installations que
nous construisons donc nous en gardons
certaines nous en exploitons beaucoup
nous avons créé des emplois pour la
maintenance de ces installations que
nous avons construit mais assez
fréquemment en effet monsieur courto
nous nous les nous les vendons alors ça
c'est sur la partie renouvelable de la
PP1 programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie sur la partie nucléaire de la
programmation pluri-annuelle de
l'énergie nous avons compris des moi
j'ai compris des dernières déclarations
qui ont été faites par le gouvernement
que d'ici au 1er juillet une
programmation de la partie nucléaire et
et peut-être d'ailleurs des autres
actifs
sera présenté par le gouvernement en
consultation notamment au Conseil
supérieur de l'énergie et nous aurons à
ce moment-là à chezedf à regarder ce que
les différents scénarios qui nous seront
présentés veulent dire
et à préparer ce que sera l'application
de cette PPE nucléaire si on peut
l'appeler comme ça au parc nucléaire de
DF à l'horizon 201 à partir de l'horizon
2018-2019 puisque c'est à l'horizon
2018-209 que devrait comm penser à si je
peux dire qu'on pourra mesurer euh
l'évolution des différents scénarios
quant à la croissance de la la
consommation
d'électrique la production d'énergie
renouvelable la production d'énergie
nucléaire les exportations qu'il ne faut
pas oublier puisqu'il y a il y a des
exportations et nous aurons à ce
moment-là à nous inscrire euh dans cette
dans cette PPE donc n'attendez pas de DF
un travail euh détaillé sur le parc de
centrale nucléaire et et la traduction
locale de ce qui pourrait se passer dans
certaines hypothèses avant cette
échéance et je rappellerai comme
d'ailleurs l'a tout à fait souligné
Madame Royale récemment je rappellerai
que tout ceci dépend de l' vie que
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire aura à
donner tranche par tranche sur chacun
des sites quant à la possibilité sur
chacun de ces site de poursuivre la
l'exploitation pendant 10 ans de plus
voir 20 ans de plus voire davantage
puisque j'ai j'ai plaisir à vous dire
que aux États-Unis notamment des
installations nucléaires dans la même
génération technologique sont en train
de dépasser les 60 ans et pour certaines
vont obtenir probablement des
autorisations d'exploitation jusqu'à 80
ans donc c'est quelque chose qu'il ne
faut pas non plus exclure sur le
territoire français et sur le parc sur
le parc français donc je pense notamment
par rapport aux questions que que posait
monsieur Dubois que je vous ai apporté
les réponses que je suis en mesure de
vous apporter de vous apporter
aujourd'hui mais j'attends aussi
monsieur le sénateur j'attends que la
PPE soit un nucléaire
soit soit précisé le président Courteau
sera aux avant-postes puisque président
du Conseil supérieur de l'énergie il
aura à connaître le premiersum les
propositions du gouvernement sera saisi
le
premier voilà je voudrais je voudrais
parler aussi de du travail que nous fait
que nous faisons dans
la structure industrielle qui nous
accompagne il y avait plusieurs
questions les questions de Madame
estroszi oui Madame nous avons des
difficultés dans certains métiers et et
et je dois vous dire que quand je visite
certains chantiers que je regarde
j'essaie de parler avec certains euh des
des opérateurs et que j'ai D du mal à
communiquer dans ma langue avec eux
c'est quelque chose que je regrette
j'aimerais bien pouvoir communiquer dans
ma propre langue avec les opérateurs qui
soudent par exemple sur sur nos
chantiers et nous avons il faut le
reconnaître un déficit aujourd'hui dans
la capacité qu' a notre système éducatif
notamment dans l'enseignement
professionnel à répondre dans certains
métiers du nucléaire je ne suis pas sûr
que ça soit le cas des cadres et des
ingénieurs je pense qu'il s'agit
plutôt plutôt des des soudeurs des des
tuyaux auteur des robinettiers des
monteurs électriques enfin dans ces
métiers là nous avons nous avons des
difficultés donc nous y travaillons
étroitement nous y travaillons notamment
parce que nous préparons le grand
carénage avec toutes les ETI et toutes
les PME qui nous qui nous accompagnent
et nous essayons de le faire dans les
bassins d'emploi dans certains bassins
d'emploi où je me suis rendu il y a des
choses très très fortes qui se qui se
font mais c'est un souci en effet
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas adéquation
entre la la demande dont nous sommes les
porteurs et et l'offre de compétences
dans certains de de nos métiers et je
crois que des évolutions sont
nécessaires dans la manière dont
sont
orienté nos jeunes concitoyens vers ces
métiers où il y a des besoins des
évolutions sont nécessaires pour que
davantage on puisse parler le français
sur nos
chantiers je
voudrais également sur la la stratégie
industrielle dire que nous travaillons
très étroitement avec les ETI et les PME
monsieur Leroi vous en aviez parlé et et
également monsieur bzino qui
s'inquiétait de notre notre stratégie
industrielle nous
avons des concertations à la fois
nationales et locales avec les
entreprises qui nous
accompagnent peut toujours faire mieux
mais je crois quand même que nous avons
mis en place tous les process toutes les
méthodes qui nous permettent de préparer
nos partenaires c'est notre intérêt
comme c'est le leur aux différents
chantiers aux différents travaux qu'ils
vont devoir faire faire pour nous voilà
et enfin sur le nucléaire je voudrais
dire un mot de démentantellement parce
que Madame bataille m'a posé des
questions sur sur
cigo monsieur laabbé également alors
d'abord soyons très très clair moi je
signe les comptes de DF et dans les
comptes de DF il y a des provisions pour
la gestion des déchets en fin de vie et
pour le démantellement des installations
et si je signe les comptes avec sérénité
comme le soulignait quelqu'un tout à
l'heure c'est parce que je me suis
assuré que ces comptes sont sincères
parce que sinon je suis en faute et je
me suis assuré notamment par exemple
s'agissant de CGO s'agissant du
démantelllement que nous avons mesuré à
leur juste valeur les dépenses qui vont
devoir être faite et nous le faisons en
fonction de notre expérience puisque
nous sommes déjà aujourd'hui en train de
démanteler certaines centrales au
graffite à Chinon à buget et cetera de
la génération précédente et que nous
avons par nous-mêmes établi des devis et
que ces devis ont été vérifiés par nos
commissaires au compte mais que
régulièrement la Cour des comptes se
penche sur ces provisions et que encore
tout récemment le ministère de
l'environnement de l'énergie et de la
mer a fait procéder à un trè audit
indépendant par des des des experts et
que
j'ai sur mon bureau le rapport des
experts commandés par le ministère le
rapport de la Cour des comptes et le
rapport de mes commissaires au comptes
qui me disent oui monsieur le Président
vous pouvez signer ces comptes parce
qu'il reflète sincèrement les dépenses
qu'il va falloir faire pour démontel le
parc et je voudrais aussi souligner que
ces activités sont pour nous projet
industriel important que j'ai d'ailleurs
réorganisé à mon arrivée en confiant à
une personne
unique le soin d'assurer la gestion
globale de nos compétences de nos
projets d'optimiser nos dépenses et que
nous nous sommes nous-même un opérateur
sur certains domaines et nous avons une
filiale qui s'appelle socod qui est
principalement basé sur la région
ronalpe et qui elle-même traite un
certain nombre de ces matériaux qu'il
faut démanteler et et gérer dans la
durée et sur CGO vous aurez remarqué que
suite à l'arrê é du ministère qui a
augmenté la dépense prévisionnelle sur
6G pendant les 130 ou 150 ans qui
viennent nous avons augmenté nous-mêmes
la provision dans nos comptes sur 6G
nous l'avons augmenté de 800 millions de
800 millions d'euros dans les comptes
que j'ai signé que Monsieur GIR
également a signé au titre de l'année
2015 donc s'il doit y avoir des dépenses
supplémentaires nous les inscrivions
dans nous les inscrivons dans nos
comptes et croyez bien et croyez bien
que je serais très mal à l'aise si je ne
reflétais pas dans les comptes que je
signe la connaissance que j'ai des
dépenses futures et donc je ne le ferai
pas je reflète cela dans euh dans nos
comptes la
su
vous il pas suprimé il est baissé de
niveau production qui finance ridicule
et qui n pr le milion d' allez
je donc
je et bien c'est une bonne transition
monsieur le sénateur pour parler
d'hydroélectricité alors je vous parle
je ne vous parlerai pas des passes à
poisson qui sont un sujet
important mais je dirais coûteux
également en vous disant que c'est un
sujet que nous prenons très au sérieux
car la France a été mise en demeure de
modifier le régime qu'elle applique
depuis une quinzaine d'années et que la
Commission de Bruxelles la direction de
la concurrence la Commission de
Bruxelles estime ne pas être conforme
aux directif que la France a elle-même
approuvé et et mise en place à la
travers des des lois successives et donc
nous avons en effet un souci c'est celui
d'assurer la continuité de la production
hydraulique et à travers la production
hydraulique la continuité de ce que nous
faisons dans les territoires dans les
vallées parce que la ressource
hydraulique bien sûr a des effets
bénéfiques sur l'irrigation et
l'agriculture sur la biodiversité sur le
tourisme et et et et bien sûr aussi sur
les ressources propres que nous payons
et je voudrais d'ailleurs rappeler que
Madame Lamur que nous payons les
redevances hydrauliques qu'elles sont
prévues dans les textes là de la même
façon j'aurais du mal à à ne pas payer
ce qui est ce qui est
prévu alors la la la commission nous a
fait savoir il y a quelques temps
qu'elle
souhaitait discuter avec l'État français
et accessoirement avec EDF de la manière
dont cette mise en demeure va être
euh de la réponse je dirais concrète et
pas simplement de la réponse juridique
une réponse juridique qui a été formulée
par l'État et EDF a également apporter
sa propre contribution cette réponse
juridique mais je crois que ce qui est
important c'est de voir comment on sort
de tout cela et donc il est un peu tôt
pour en parler puisque le message que
nous avons de la commission est récent
mais ce message c'est un message bien
asseyons-nous autour d'une table et
discutons de la manière dont les choses
vont évoluer des appels d'offres seront
sûrement lancés à un certain moment bien
évidemment
EDF y répondra c'est une évidence nous
souhaitons conserver notre patrimoine je
crois que nous faisons un bon travail en
matière d'exploitation du système
hydraulique hydraulique français et nous
avons d'ailleurs en tête que le
potentiel hydraulique français pourrait
être dans certaines conditions encore
amélioré avec certaines infrastructures
qui n'ont pas été construites ces
dernières années qui pourrai l'être si
les conditions étaient était
réunis voilà je pense avoir à peu près
répondu sur sur l'hydraolique je
voudrais dire un mot de RTE notamment
madame bataille a parlé de de
RTE monsieur gr aussi comment
voyons-nous
RTE
il y a aujourd'hui une situation qui est
un peu curieuse pour quelqu'un qui comme
moi vient de l'extérieur et qui
s'aperçoit que RTE est détenu à 100 %
par EDF mais que compte tenu du rôle
essentiel de RTE pour assurer
une répartition juste
des con des connexions des moyens de
production au au réseau de
transport dans sa grande et on peut
comprendre pourquoi le régulateur impose
à EDF de ne pas se mêler des affaires de
RTE d'ailleurs je répondrai cétait l'une
des l'une des dernières questions
monsieur CALV que je ne suis pas capable
de vous parler du fonctionnement de la
ligne avec l'Espagne car c'est RTE qui
s'en occupe et que je n'ai même pas le
droit de poser la question en pratique
mais vous vous avez le droit de poser la
question à Monsieur Brot lorsque vous le
verrez et donc et donc le l'étanchéité
de dans la gestion dans le
fonctionnement dans le management entre
rTE etdf est total et néanmoins nous
détenons 100 % du capital de RTE et donc
nous avons un projet qui s'inscrit dans
la loi actuelle donc qui ne prévoit pas
de changer les disposition législative
qui impose que la totalité du capital du
RTE soit détenu par des structures du du
public des structures publiques donc à
l'intérieur de ce cadre où tous les tous
les actionnaires de RTS sont public nous
avons le projet d'ouvrir le capital dès
lors que cela s'inscr insrit dans le
projet d'entreprise dans la stratégie
que François Brot et ses équipes sont en
train de de de préparer et ce projet le
gouvernement a demandé à à François Brot
et à moi-même de le préparer au
printemps et de le mettre en place cette
année j'espère que ça pourra être fait
car ça pourrait je crois donner une
ouverture stratégique importante à RTE
mais c'est à François Brod de le dire et
ça pourrait aussi donner à EDF une
vision quand même plus logique de son
patrimoine
puisque détenir un actif à 100 % mais ne
pas pouvoir le gérer c'est quand même un
petit peu bizarre si vous me permettez
si vous me
permettez n fir François Brot président
de
RTE voilà vous aviez des questions sur
les effectifs oui alors je voudrais vous
dire que les effectifs de DF ont
beaucoup augmenté ces dernières années
de bien plus que 3000 ou 4000 emplois
plutôt de l'ordre de 10000 et donc là
maintenant nous allons les faire baisser
un peu par rapport à une augmentation
forte qui a eu lieu ces dernières années
et pourquoi cette augmentation forte et
bien parce que nous avions beaucoup
embauché lorsque le programme
électronucléaire a été lancé ça
doit-être du temps du du président
Pompidou ou du des début de la du
président guscardestin et et nous avions
beaucoup embauché et donc nous devons
nous préoccuper de remplacer les
compétences et notamment dans certains
métiers du nucléaire on ne devient pas
expert compétent pour gérer des sujets
qui sont difficiles simplement avec
quelques mois de de formation il faut
plutôt parler d'années entre la
formation un peu théorique et puis la
formation sur le terrain et nous avons
organisé ce ce un dispositif dans lequel
nous avons beaucoup embauché au début de
la décennie comme je le disais tout à
l'heure nous avons formé les personnes
que nous avons embauché nous les avons
mis en binôme avec les anciens un
mentoring comme on dit aujourd'hui et
puis maintenant les anciens partent à la
retraite et les nouveaux sont déjà là
parce qu'ils ont été embauchés il y a
quelques années et que nous allons ainsi
pouvoir opérer exploiter le réseau en
toute sûreté avec une très bonne
performance industrielle et en ne
remplaçant pas en effet la totalité des
départs en retraite mais ce que nous
prévoyons je voudrais souligner c'est
que nous allons au total si on prend
cette espèce de bosse suivi d'une
réduction nous allons avoir au total
plus d'emplois chez F on peut
s'interroger là-dessus que nous n'en
avions au début de la décenie
alors même que la consommation
n'augmente pas ce qui évidemment est
quelque chose qui nous nous nous
interpelle mais à ce stade nous
prévoyons donc ces diminutions qui sont
tout à fait sous contrôle évidemment il
continuera à y avoir des embauches et
notamment faire en sorte que le réseau
dans sa capillarité locale continue à à
bien fonctionner nous continuerons aussi
à embaucher en matière de recherche et
développement et Monsieur Bosino
s'inquiétait de de de de ce sujet donc
nous continuerons à à embaucher de façon
à mener la totalité des missions qui qui
sont les nôtres néanmoins il y aura
certaines certaines réduction
d'effectifs et en ce qui concerne les
économies madame bataille notamment
avait abordé ce ce sujet et bien nous
allons travailler sur le cadre du plan
général qui a été présenté en conseil
d'administration nous allons travailler
à mettre en place les économies qui
correspondent à cette nouvelle
trajectoire je voudrais répondre sur le
sujet
de des actifs thermiques et notamment
madame primat nous avons un projet à
Porcheville qui est aujourd'hui en
consultation nous avons sur sur
Porcheville
ouvert un dialogue social avec les
instances représentatives du personnel
pour préparer une éventuelle mise à
l'arrêt de Porcheville un peu plus tôt
que prévu nous le prévoyons précédemment
début des années 2020 nous envisageons
de le faire en 2018 et pourquoi cela et
bien parce que même dans les cas
aujourd'hui que je citais de de risque
sur le réseau il n'y a pas aujourd'hui
de rentabilité mais il n'y a même pas
non plus de fonctionnement les ces
installations d'ailleurs je soulligne
que deux des quatre tranches ont déjà
été fermé en
2008 deux des quatre tranches ont été
fermé dans 2008 il reste deux tranches
il reste environ 190 salariés quelqu
dizaines de prestataires et donc nous
projetons nous projetons cette fermeture
nous en discutons avec
les autorités politiques locales
également j'ai rencontré Monsieur Bédier
qui est le président du conseil général
des ivelines et nous essayons de voir
avec lui comment optimiser la gestion du
site avec une partie du site qui est
destiné à rester chez EDF mais une
partie du site sur laquelle nous
envisageons avec le Conseil Général donc
de euh mettre à disposition ou de céder
du terrain pour revitaliser ce site qui
a une vocation industrielle m'a dit
Monsieur Bédier mais c'est à Lui
d'organiser
son ces choses-là donc je suis très
attentif au au cas de de Porcheville et
bien évidemment pour les effectifs
concernés pour les prestataires
concernés nous ferons bien les choses
puisque nous avons des cellules de
reclassement qui se mettront en place le
moment venu puisqueaujourd'hui la
décision n'est pas formellement prise
elle est encore dans le cadre de la euh
de la
consultation je vrais parler un petit
peu de recherche et développement pour
vous dire que nous essayons euh avec les
moyens qui sont les nôtres et vous aviez
des questions euh vous étiez assez
nombreux à avoir des des questions
là-dessus monsieur Bourquin notamment
euh
euh l'hydrogène voilà Monsieur R d'une
certaine façon à travers les objets
connectés nous essayons de répartir nos
dépenses de recherche et développement
je rappelle qu'elles sont 600 millions
d'euros par an nous essayons de les
répartir en fonction de nos différents
objectifs stratégiques fait faire que
dans une entreprise la recherche et
développement soit cohérente avec la
stratégie la stratégie cap 2030 dont
dont je parlais donc nous avons bien
évidemment une partie importante de
notre recherche et développement dans le
domaine de la production classique si je
puis dire le nucléaire euh la production
euh de d'énergie renouvelable
l'hydraulique que nous sur lequel nous
nous travaillons aussi pour certaines
optimisations notamment sur le centre de
Chatou mais nous essayons aussi
d'anticiper ce que va être le marché de
l'énergie dans les années qui viennent
donc nous avons de nombreux travaux en
matière de recherche et développement
autour des réseau
intelligents autour de l'utilisation du
numérique pour optimiser
l'efficacité d'efficacité de notre
production et au niveau de l'utilisation
des technologies numériques pour pour
optimiser la manière dont nos clients
dans les territoires vont eux-mêmes
optimiser leur consommation organiser
les moyens de production locaux nous
avons un un un très gros chantier qui
est mené sous lesgit de RDF en matière
de Smart Grid parce que la gestion d'un
réseau si je peux dire centralisé c'est
entre guillemets simple c'est évidemment
très compliqué mais c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué d'avoir un réseau dans lequel
en fonction de de de caractéristiques
qui peuvent aller et venir très vite
comme le vent et le soleil vous devez
injecter localement de très très très
nombreuses installations qui viennent se
substituer au courant qui venait qui
vient de de du du réseau centralisé donc
le les les smart grid sont des des
sujets très importants nous avons des
expérimentations j'en ai j'en ai visité
trois dans trois trois grandes villes en
France à Lyon à Nice et à Toulouse et
nous essayons de faire en sorte que que
nous soyons au premier plan parce que
c'est un sujet tout à fait majeur c'est
un sujet qui intéresse les territoires
qui intéresse les métropoles mais aussi
les territoires en général et et donc
nous essayons d'être d'être présent
là-dessus et
d'insérer petit à petit le compteur link
key dans un écosystème qui lui permettra
de rendre tous les services qu'on peut
attendre du compteur Linky et je
voudrais dire un mot là-dessus d'abord
le compteur Linky ne rendra ses services
qu'à ceux des clients de DF ou des
concurrents DF qui le souhaitent ce sont
des systèmes où il faut être volontair
pour inséré dans un écosystème
d'optimisation de la consommation les
informations du compteur Linky elles ne
sont disponibles que pour que aerdf pour
faire la facturation et ce ne sont que
les Français qui décideront qu' qu'ils
veulent participer à un système
d'optimisation de leur consommation
d'électricité qui pourront donner le
droit à leur prestataires d'accéder à
des informations de Linky mais les
Français qui ne le souhaitent pas et
bien le la seule information de Linky ce
sera l'information de comptage qui
permet la facturation à à à à DF et je
voudrais souligner parce qu'on parle
d'électrosensibilité que d'abord nous
avons en effet quelques quelques soucis
avec des communes de ça et là qui n'ont
pas l'air enthousiaste à l'idée qu'il y
a un compteur numérique et qui délibère
dans ce sens et que nous essayons de
leur faire comprendre par différents
moyens que la loi doit s'imposer partout
et puis nous avons aussi quelques
quelques personnes qui s'inquiètent d'un
d'un compteur et euh moi je voudrais
simplement rappeler que les émissions
euh d'ond radioélectrique par par le
compteur Linky sont extrêmement modestes
euh elles sont très très inférieures par
exemple à ce que sont les émissions
d'objets ménagés tels que les fours à
micro-ondes par exemple qui émettent
beaucoup ou même la plupart des des des
objets que nous que nous utiliserons
donc euh je crois qu'il faut essayer
d'être raisonnable sur sur ces sujets-là
voilà je vais terminer peut-être si vous
me le permettez j'espère avoir à peu
près oui je rassure sur les questions
financières sur les questions
financières le prix du baril la loi Nome
et tout ça alors le prix du baril c'est
le d'abord il est un peu remonté il est
plus autour de 45 dollars aujourd'hui
que que de 30 bon euh le prix du charbon
lui n'a pas vraiment remonté donc il
faut regarder la corrélation entre les
différentes énergies euh le le le prix
du baril a un peu remonté le prix du
charbon n'a pas remonté parce qu'il y a
le phénomène du gaz de schiste aux
États-Unis qui fait qu'il y a trop plein
de charbon aux États-Unis qui se déverse
en Europe et que ceci a a abaissé les
prix de l'électricité de façon
considérable alors à ces prix-l bien sûr
laaren et la loi nomme ne s'applique pas
on est tous d'accord là-dessus
hein nous avons l'obligation de vendre à
42 € du mgawh une partie de notre
production nucléaire mais quelqu'un qui
peut l'acheter à 28 € du mgawh on voit
pas pourquoi il aurait l'acheté à 42
donc depuis maintenant de semestres nous
ne vendons plus du tout du tout
d'électricité à au prix au prix de la
reen ce qui d'ailleurs amène à
s'interroger sur cette partie-là de la
loi Nome et ce système dans lequel quand
les prix sont élevés c'est au détriment
deedf et quand les prix sont bas c'est
au détriment deedf c'est pas un très bon
système on aimerait trouver mieux je
suis d'accord avec vous monsieur le
monsieur le le sénateur c'est pas c'est
pas ce qu'il y a de
mieux voilà alors au total nous avons
donc cette situation financière dont je
parlais je répondrai au sénateur
poniatovski que nous avons optimisé le
les investissements du grand carénage
d'environ 15 % et qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui de 51 milliards d'euros
courant alors qu'ils étaient
préalablement de 55 milliards d'euros en
EURO 2012 donc nous sommes passés des
euros 2012 aux euros courants de 55 à 51
et donc c'est c'est voilà c'est sur la
période 2014-2025 je répond V aussi au
sénateur patovski que nous avons
l'intention sur Areva de dépenser non
pas 2 milliards et demi d'euros mais la
moitié de cette somme puisque nous avons
l'intention d'acheter 51 % d'Areva et
non pas 100 % Areva luiême d'Areva NP
pardon Areva lui-même va garder une
partie d'Areva NP
et nous
aurons j'espère des partenaires nous
discutons avec eux des partenaires
asiatiques qui prendront une partie du
capital dans le cadre de partenariat
stratégique que nous avons avec ces euh
ses partenaires asiatiques d'un côté nos
amis chinois et de l'autre côté nos amis
nos amis japonais et puis notutre dette
vous l'avez souligné elle a augmenté
chaque année la dette comptable est
aujourd'hui de 37 milliards d'euros
c'est un chiffre qui est élevé il y a
des engagements hors bilan qui rendent
les agences de
notation dans
une situation d'examen détaillé de notre
capacité à rembourser cette
dette parce que nous avons av des
engagements qui sont orbilant notamment
en matière de retraite et que nous avons
donc des des
perspectives qui mérite une grande
attention il faut que nous puissions en
toutes circonstances lever la dette sur
les marchés dont nous avons besoin pour
renouveler cette dette sur les trois
prochaines années pas de pas de de
de difficultés particulières puisque
nous avons assez peu de remboursement de
dett à renouveler par contre à l'horizon
2020 nous avons beaucoup de dettes à
renouveler et notamment une dette
hybride qui a été construite en 2013 et
et 2014 et qui nécessite qu'on regarde
les choses avec beaucoup de de
précaution et donc l'évolution de la
dette je crois que je l'avais dit
d'ailleurs lors de mon arrivée est
vraiment un sujet de préoccupation et de
ce point de
vue-là l'impact d'une recapitalisation
deedf à travers les mesures prises sur
le dividende et la l'augmentation de
capital que nous préparons pour la fin
de cette année il est réel il est
significatif c'est un impact qui est
significatif et les choses ont été
calculé par nous de manière à rendre nos
investissements et notre bilan cohérent
nous aurons après cette augmentation de
capital les moyens de financer nos
investissements et les moyens de faire
le grand carénage je répond aussi au
sénateur patovski par nous-même nous
n'avons pas l'intention aujourd'hui
d'ouvrir le capital de nos centrales
nucléaires il y a quelques centrales
mais c'est très mineur dont
les des participations très minoritaires
à ch à buget je crois
fenheim ch bet fenhe il y a quelques
participations et aussi et
Tricastin mais aujourd'hui nous détenons
quasiment 100 % de ce parc et nous nous
notre intention est de continuer à
détenir 100 % de ce parc sur les
sessions d'actif je répond à Monsieur
monsieur
Vincent
nous
il le cont je dirais qu'en effet nous
prévoyons de vendre 10 milliards d'euros
d'actif mais que nous n'avons pas de
répartition détaillée année par année
mais sur ces 10 milliards d'euros si
nous nous en arrivions à vendre 6
milliards dès cette année je trouveraai
ça formidable je pense pas qu'on y
arrivera je pense qu'il faut mieux
imaginer que sur les années 2016 2017
quelque chose d'un peu écou iréparti et
et quelque chose d'un peu lissé non pas
que évidemment si nous nous arrivons à
bien vendre très vite les actifs que
nous voulons vendre on aura fait un très
bon travail mais nous sommes plus
prudents que cela dans nos prévisions de
de trajectoire de trajectoire financière
voilà je crois que j'en ai à peu près
terminé sur la quasi totalité des des
sujets vous m'aviez parlé de l'incidence
de la baisse du cours de bourse sur
l'entreprise et bien je dirais qu'elle
est indirecte elle est indirect
puisqueaujourd'hui l'entreprise constate
que le cours de bourse a baissé
que les investisseurs qui étaient
rentrés au moment de la mise en Bourse
ou qui ont acheté des titres sur le
marché on ont perdu de l'argent ce qui
est parfaitement regrettable et je pense
notamment au fait que certains salariés
eux-mêmes on ont souscrit et n'ont pas
fait une bonne affaire mais aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas d'effet direct sur
l'entreprise c'est plutôt notre
réputation notre image ou l'image que
peut avoir l'entreprise lorsqu'elle lève
de la dette alors nous avons levé de la
dette sans difficulté en octobre 2015
nous avons euh une très bonne couverture
par les marchés de dette de l'évolution
des choses donc nous n'avons pas de
tension aujourd'hui sur ce qu'on appelle
le CDS c'est-à-dire la prime de risque
qui est mise sur la dette de DF je
m'excuse c'est un peu technique donc
notre dette se tient bien comme l'on dit
mais nous sommes extrêmement vigilants
parce qu'entre le cours de bourse et la
croissance régulière de l'endettement de
DF nous ne pouvons pas laisser les
choses dériver et c'est pour cela que
nous avons préparé présenter euh au
conseil d'administration le plan que je
vous ai décrit aujourd'hui voilà j'ai à
peu près terminé je vous remercie
monsieur sur en ce qui concerne la
Dominique je j'ai compris que cette
cette installation le l'appel d'offre
avait été remporté par un concurrent et
ce sont des choses qui arrivent et euh
et euh
euh
pardon au départou Tréf a tradé ou c'est
pas très favorable ah c'est
possible vous savez nous nous nous ne
nous n'avons vocation à répondre à
beaucoup d'appels d'offre mais il faut
aussi de temps en temps accepter de ne
pas t gagner monsieur président au
moment où tout le monde se la je
voudrais vraiment vous remercier pour la
précision des réponses que vous avez
apporté il y a eu beaucoup de questions
vous l'avez vu tout le monde a été
extrêmement respectueux du temps de
parole vous vousmême dans un temps
finalement relativement court avez
apporté je crois beaucoup beaucoup de
répones écoutez merci encore d'être venu
ici et nous poursuivrons nos échanges
avec en
effet François
Brot qui sera invité à venir devant nous
la séance est levée
merci voilà pour l'audition de
Jean-Bernard levvi le patron de DF le
géant français de l'électricité
Jean-Bernard levvi qui est revenu sur la
situation financière du groupe à
l'occasion de cette audition devant les
sénateurs de la commission des affaires
économiques et qui a également défendu
le projet de PR d'inkle point en
Grande-Bretagne vous pouvez toujours
voir et revoir toutes les auditions sur
notre site publsena.fr très bonne
journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires